programming throwdown episode 132 funding open source projects take it away jason hey everybody so uh if that voice sounded different to you, that's because we have Adam from Co-Recursive on the show. So thanks so much, Adam, for coming on. Thanks for having me. I'm super excited. Cool. Yeah, Patrick is getting a tan.
He is on vacation. And part of us wanting to do two shows a month and trying to make the show more oriented or focused is trying to make sure we actually put out that show and that content. We have a ton of stuff we want to talk about. And so I think it's great that when one of us is out, instead of us just not, you know, making that content and pushing everything back, that we find folks who are friends of ours, who love podcasting and love tech to jump in. And so Adam's doing that for Patrick. So thank you again, Adam, for coming on. Yeah, no problem. I'm excited. Anytime, by the way. Yeah. Cool.
We'll take you up on that. Yeah, I think I'm planning on being out in July. So we'll see how that all goes. But cool. So yeah, I wanted to start by just jumping into gaming setups i recently redid the gaming setup i had in my living room and i was pretty stoked about it you know i have i'm really big into the whole emulator scene you know i worked on maim for a long time and all of that and so i've always had a kind of special place in my heart for those like retro games like snes and n64 and all of these things and so i have accumulated over the years like usb versions of all of these controllers i don't know if they even had wireless when i started this collection but i just kind of stuck with the whole wire thing and so i have you know those like big they call them fight sticks but
they're big it looks kind of like you took the the controller part of an arcade cabinet and just ripped it out and just it's this big thing it's like it weighs it has a weight in it so it's heavy it's got the big buttons and it's got the octagonal joystick and everything and so you just kind of it's like putting an arcade uh controller in your lap that's awesome so you rest it on your lap and then does it give you the feel yeah yeah exactly yeah it gives you a feel it's got the uh yeah the big buttons everything so i've got those i have two of those i have two of the snes controllers the ones i got are the like buffalo brand or i buffalo brand they're solid i mean they've lasted forever and so similar
i have all sorts of different ones and so here I am with all these controllers, they're all USB. And when I play on my computer, that'd be fine. But I wanted to play in the living room. And so what I used to do is I used to have just a really long USB extension. But I think USB can go like 50 feet or something. I think occasionally we would lose like an input but it wasn't too bad but it's kind of janky and you people are tripping over it and everything so what i found online on amazon i didn't know this existed but blew my mind is it's a usb dongle
and what comes out the other end is an ethernet port and then you can run ethernet cable like through the wall in your house so i have this going from the tv through the wall and then it comes up where my couch is and so i actually took the the other end of it is a usb hub so the ethernet plugs into this usb hub and i have that kind of attached to my couch. And so I can actually plug controllers into the couch and they work with the TV. I have a big fan. Yeah, it was amazing. I found it to be really low latency, which I guess in hindsight, isn't that surprising? Because, you know, we have Cat5 running through the house for, you know, online gaming and all of that. But yeah, for some reason, I just thought that with all these moving, with all these parts, that there would
be some kind of issue, but it works works flawlessly and we have a little cabinet right behind the couch you can kind of reach behind you pull out you know a snes controller and then have at it that's amazing we have this mocha have you ever heard of mocha no i haven't okay so our house does not have ethernet throughout the house so this is not so much gaming as internet so mocha is i think multimedia over coax so the the coax cables that they did run through the house you can get this like mocha controller and you plug ethernet in one side and then coax the other side and then it runs a high speed ethernet over top of these coax cables wow really yeah so that's what we're talking on right now so for whatever reason like
the hookup i have fiber coming into the house that's super fast but then like wi-fi could barely make it from the basement where the setup is like anywhere else right but you put in these mocha things and like it's super high speed like it it doesn't slow it down at all that is awesome you'll have to look into that yeah my house actually i ran this cat6 cable just for this but other than that it has similar to you has as cable as coax all over the house which we're not even using right now yeah and like you a lot of people will try to get there there's, there's like power line ethernet where you run it over your plugs.
Oh, I've seen that in the store, but I didn't really understand it totally. Yeah. So I guess it's not as good because like there's other things going on. Like, you know, you get interference from the actual products that you plug in. Right. That's what I thought would happen. Yeah. Yeah.
Where your coax cable, I guess has lots of bandwidth, but the Mocha controllers are more expensive. Like it's a proprietary thing. Oh, I see. But it's awesome. I totally recommend it. That is super cool. My parents recently ditched their cable provider and got 5G home internet, which I didn't even know was a thing. But yeah, that was pretty cool. I helped them set it up. It's like, this is like every tech son has to do this, like go to their parents' house, try to fix their internet. And so it came in the mail from T-Mobile. And it took me forever to figure out like where to plug in the cable line because I didn't know what they had gotten. And then I'm like reading instructions. And then finally it hit me. It's like, oh, this is like a 5G thing. It just plugs into the wall and that's it you're done
and my first reaction was oh this internet can't be that great but it's amazing like the speed test i think it was 15 megabytes per second down which is huge yeah i mean i don't it's probably more than what i have and uh yeah phenomenal quality i mean it's just this little tower looks like a mac pro trash can you know like one of those form factors and yeah I thought that was really impressive so it's basically a cell phone that we're using 5g that provides yeah that's all it is but yeah it gets a amazing maybe it has a stronger antenna not sure but it gets amazing transfer speeds it's actually pretty big so it must be basically just a giant antenna yeah a whole bunch of in yeah composite antenna inside somehow yeah right cool um so your gaming setup is nintendo switch oh yeah so i'm not
a hardcore gamer but like me and my wife always like to play mario kart so who's better she she is clearly better my wife is way better too there's just something about i forget which i think it was on the wii maybe years ago and uh yeah she just played it so often against me and and she just got so good and and now we play online, like we have like Nintendo online or whatever. So we're competing against, you know, 13 year olds from all over the world. Yeah, that's right. I remember, I mean, this is a, I'm sure it's a very common thing, but you play in your social network, your local hyperlocal network.
And you think I have to be the best in the world. I mean, I've beaten every person in my neighborhood. And then you go to play mario kart online it's like oh yeah i guess you could leave a banana peel right there so that someone misses the jump and dies like you know it's something i really thought about yeah they're amazing if you play online it's really i mean i guess that should be a surprise to no one but yeah yeah yeah exactly same thing happened with starcraft this is a really long time ago but this is like 1998 or something starcraft one you know we had a little tournament a land party tournament at our high school and there was this guy who won it and i also i think i came in second or third and then we thought oh if we form a team of the two of us you know we have
to be the best in the world and we just got completely demolished by people as you said people from all over the world have you ever seen that documentary the king of kong oh that is amazing such a good documentary what is that gentleman's name they got the long hair i'll look it up yeah but it's about a guy it's pac-man right no it's king kong right king kong yeah that's right he's gonna beat the world champion surprise like surprisingly a lot of drama in a thing about people competing with arcade games billy mitchell that's who it is yeah so billy mitchell was uh i think he made hot sauce yeah his like day job was making hot sauce and then on the side, he just played Donkey Kong endlessly. I guess Donkey Kong's way harder than I thought
to be the best in the world and we just got completely demolished by people as you said people from all over the world have you ever seen that documentary the king of kong oh that is amazing such a good documentary what is that gentleman's name they got the long hair i'll look it up yeah but it's about a guy it's pac-man right no it's king kong right king kong yeah that's right he's gonna beat the world champion surprise like surprisingly a lot of drama in a thing about people competing with arcade games billy mitchell that's what it is yeah so billy mitchell was uh i think he made hot sauce yeah his like day job was making hot sauce and then on the side, he just played Donkey Kong endlessly. I guess Donkey Kong's way harder than I thought
before I saw the movie. Yeah, there's whole intricacies to it that I wasn't aware of, but also he was quite the character, like quite a, at least portrayed as quite a villain. Yeah, yeah, definitely. Definitely a larger-than-life character. That's a phenomenal movie, by the way, King of Kong, highly, definitely. Definitely larger than life character. That's a phenomenal movie, by the way.
King of Kong, highly recommend it. Have you seen the movie, somewhat similar in the sense of like a documentary, a class action park? It's on HBO Max. Is this the water slide place? Yeah, yeah. Oh my gosh.
So folks out there should check this out. There's this water park in i think the 80s and 90s called action park and their claim one of their claim to fames was a loop-de-loop a vertical loop-de-loop water slide so basically like it's exactly what you would think like you'd see in a roller coaster where you know you go down this water slide and you build up so much speed you can literally do a loop-de-loop and just the g-forces are holding you against the edge of the loop-de-loop until they don't so so it turns out if your weight if you're either too light or too heavy from this like pretty tight bound then you would not get
enough momentum and what would happen is you would get you know near the top and then you would smack you know the inside of the wall of the loop on your way down. And this is just one of the attractions that they talk about in class action park. The thing that blew my mind was not only the obvious like, oh my God, I can't believe that they're able to run for 20, 30 years. But then also the fact that a lot of the rides later came from those ideas. So those ideas actually spawned a lot of, you know, safe rides. So in a sense, it was like a necessary evil or something. But man, it's an unbelievable story.
Yeah, they were quite innovative, but horrible. Like they, I think in the thing it said, like the local municipality was upset because they had to send ambulances there so much to get people and so they bought them an ambulance they're like here you go yeah problem solved dedicated ambulance for this theme park they had one section where you would drive uh golf carts with armor and little uh cannonball cannons that would shoot tennis balls and if the tennis ball hit the armor there was some vibration sensor on there and if it felt enough of an impact it would start spinning the tank around and these are all gasoline powered and people were passing out from the fumes because and all
this crazy stuff but then it turns out i went to disney this is years ago but much many years after action park had shut down and disney actually had the same ride i mean of course much safer electric and and they're using foam balls not tennis balls and everything but it's actually super super fun and it was inspired by action parks that's awesome yeah innovators yeah definitely yeah it's kind of that yang, that kind of like chaotic energy, you know. Cool. All right, on to news. So my news, first news item is really interesting. The title is I Was Wrong, CRDTs of the Future. And this is from Joseph Gentle.
Yeah, Joseph Gentle. And so people who might have heard of Joseph. So Joseph worked on Google Wave, which was a really old product that died, but kind of, you know, a lot of that carried over into Google Docs and some of these other things. So the Google Wave, I think, predates all of that stuff. And it was the first time where you could really edit a document in real time with other people and they could see your changes in real time. And so it was really exciting seeing sort of that tech on the web. And then of course, Google Docs, now it's ubiquitous.
And so all of that worked with something called operational transformations, or OTs. And the way it works is basically, you know, imagine, just take a string, for example, there's some long string, and I go and i delete a section of that string right maybe i delete three lines this means a multi-line string i go and delete like three lines of it so ot will send a command to the server saying you know jason deleted you know this position to this position and then let's say adam at the same time deletes something else, like maybe a non-fully overlapping section of text. So Adam submits a delete right at the same time.
So the server is going to get those two commands and the server is going to be smart enough to reconcile that conflict. So it's going to say, okay, now Jason's command came in first. Let's do the delete. When Adam's command comes in, in addition to the delete command and what he wants to delete, there's also a hash saying this is sort of a hash of the state of the string when I wanted to do my delete. Or you could use a timestamp. There's other ways to do it. So the system will say, okay, when Adam was doing his delete, you know, this text was there
that's been deleted. And so, you you know now if i sort of fast forward that change then we only actually need to delete this much text and now we have adam semantically we have what adam wanted to delete and what jason wanted to delete right and so you have this server that's you know similar to when you do get pull right you have this server it's like fast forwarding these requests as they come in because the requests are based on old state, right? And the server is also taking those requests once they've been reconciled and pushing them
so that everyone has the latest information, right? And so there's this constant back and forth going on. Now, it's complicated to get that right. There's share.js and like a bunch of libraries that do this for you now. Complicated to get it right, but it's complicated to get that right. There's Share.js and a bunch of libraries that do this for you now. Complicated to get it right, but it's simple to understand. The problem with OT is you have that server. You have to have that one authority who's making all of those judgment calls and doing all of that fast forwarding. And so you have naturally a bottleneck there. So CRDTs is a like truly distributed way to do it,
where you don't need a server, you're kind of achieving a consensus among a group of people. And so it could be, you know, in theory, completely serverless and peer to peer. And so super, super exciting, really hard to get right. Because as you can imagine, there's no authority. And so that just makes everything so much harder. But like everything, you know, over time, hard things become easier. And Joseph Gentle has decided that after spending a decade on OTs, that CRDTs have just gotten to the point now where that's the way to go. And he's actually going to drop all of his OT work and switch over to CRDTs, which is pretty
wild to see. That's cool. I think that Martin, another guy, Martin Kleppman, I think is his name who wrote. Yeah, that's right. Designing data intensive applications or something. He's been working on CRDTs for some time now, I think one of the JavaScript projects. So just seeing him interested in it made me think like, oh, I think there's something here, you know, that this can be unlocked. Yeah, totally agree. Yeah, and he's called out by name in this article.
And so, yeah, I actually, I know a lot about OTs. I implemented an operational transform. That's basically how MAME Hub and how the network Mame stuff works. I guess tying this back to the intro. So you would do button presses and then it would sort of fast forward your button presses. But yeah, so I definitely want to learn about CRDTs and maybe we'll do a follow up show on CRDTs and how they work.
Because at the moment, I know almost nothing. I'm just really excited that all these people who know this field better than anyone are getting on board. So there's just clearly something amazing here. It's just to digest it. Yeah, the conflicts, I think is the tricky part. And I guess they've figured that out. That's why it's conflict free. So for myself, I saw this article that was called how we lost 54,000 GitHub stars. It's kind of a sad story. So there's this open source library called, I don't know if it's HTTP or HTTP. Anyways, I've used it before. Let's say it's HTTP, HTTP. I think it's pi. Yeah. Yeah. So it's a replacement for curl with some really nice defaults so that it's it's easy to get
back like a json document it auto formats it and like it prettifies it it has some nice default so like it assumes a get if it makes sense you could send like key values and in a really nice way so it's has a lot of nice syntactic sugar for making these rest requests and it's not a new project it's been around for 10 years has a website you know very heavily invested in well-polished open source project and so the author of it he was working on the project and also working on a personal project and i think he wanted to make a change to something on his personal github and so he decided to make it private so he hit the like yes in github i to make this private. But he wasn't under his own name. Actually, he was under the the HTTPy organization. Oh, no. So accidentally took it private. And then when he turned it back
public, the star count had reset to zero. So somewhere inside the internal implementation details of GitHub, if you take a project private and then bring it back, like that counter resets. So 10 years of people following on GitHub was lost. That is unbelievable. I mean, it kind of makes sense. Like if something is private, then only the people who have access to it can star it so probably in this case is nobody and so but that's rough yeah it's rough so i mean the blog post was actually nice though because he kind of said like oh here's what happened so fyi if you were following us you might want to do it again and then he also said like here's the things that we've planned like we're still doing lots of stuff
and so he's focused on the positive i guess but it was an interesting story and a warning for us who have open source projects not to turn it on and off again yeah that is unbelievable yeah i mean it's really rough i mean there's not really any way to it's i think in general configuration changes are the cause of so many issues it's just extremely hard to test something like that and you know almost every time i don't want to say every time but almost every time you go to the news and you see you know google is down youtube is down facebook is down it's almost always a configuration change yeah totally 99 out of 100 times because it's like the thing that you can't test well right you just kind of got to make the
change yeah yeah exactly especially you start dealing with dns and these other things it's like the thing that you can't test well right you just kind of got to make the change yeah yeah exactly especially you start dealing with dns and these other things it's really hard dns is the worst dns is brutal i mean it's like email you know the protocol was invented so long ago and that's just you know everyone's on it and what are you going to do you know i mean the dns might actually be you know perfectly fine and a great protocol it's just it's a distributed protocol right where people are caching things and so it's very as corner cases yeah exactly yeah it'd be nice if dns worked more like git where somehow like in your i guess it does or it could like it'd be nice if you could somehow change like every dns change could somehow only affect your company and so then you know you would you would kick your entire company
off of google or facebook or something before you'd kick the public off but then you could somehow like push that change to everyone else i mean yeah that's actually dns would be another really interesting show, but we'd have to get somebody who deeply understands it. But yeah, I think that's fascinating. So my next topic is Dali, making fun of the,
or I guess an homage to Salvador Dali, creating images from text. This is from OpenAI. This is super, super cool. And yet they're getting a lot of flack saying they cherry pick these examples and everything. I mean, I don't want to dispute any of that. But all I have to say is, this is really cool. I mean, the way they presented this is really exciting. The choices are really nice. It's extremely compelling. And so what this does
is you give DALI a text prompt, and the AI generates images. And it's remarkable. Like I'm just looking at the site here. This says that the first one's an illustration of a baby daikon radish in a tutu walking a dog. And it just does it like there it is, you know, and an armchair in the shape of an avocado. And it's exactly what it sounds like. It's a chair in the shape of an avocado. And it's exactly what it sounds like. It's a chair in the shape of an avocado. Yeah, just amazing. I mean, it blows my mind. I feel like there's so much potential here.
There's so many amazing things people could do. I think that, you know, there's an uncanny valley here. So I'm looking at the last one. It says a cat on top and a sketch. Or sorry, the exact same cat on top as a sketch on the bottom so in other words it wants the ai to generate a picture of a cat and then a sketch of the same cat below it that seems really hard i mean it does it the thing is you know anything that's you know an animal or a person you know there's this's this, it has to be super, super accurate. And so this is just weird looking to be honest, but for things that are kind of abstractions like concept
art, it does an amazing job. And I mean, I'm just waiting for somebody, some really creative person to do something truly, you know, earth shattering with this because you have effectively an infinite amount of graphical content here. Yeah, it's so neat to play. Like, I don't have access to it, but there was some earlier versions of this that were open source and were more limited. But it's very fun to like put in a phrase and see what you get.
Like, yeah, it's just, it's amazing. Yeah, you know, I mean, here's a very simple thing. And maybe someone out there should do this. If you do this, I would love, you know, at us on Twitter. Adam, what are you on Twitter? Are you co-recursive? Adam Gordon Bell. Adam Gordon Bell.
Okay, at Adam Gordon Bell at Neural Nets for Life. At us if you do this. I'd love to see this. Basically, just take a text game and, you know, just put a picture next to it. So whatever the description that comes out of the text game, you just set put a picture next to it so whatever the description that comes out of the text game you just set up a two-paned type thing and just have a picture next to it i think that'd be amazing there is there's this thing called z machine which is a sort of a virtual machine for text-based games and so it was created to play zork and so all of the zork games use z machine
and it just became that for adventure games, it became sort of the gold standard. And so there's probably over 100 text-based adventure games you can play on Z Machine. And so someone would just have to fork Z Machine or even just fork a front end for Z Machine, like Frotz or one of these things, and just make it draw the dolly picture next to it i think it'd be super fun definitely there was a twitter thread where somebody was taking people's profile descriptions on twitter and feeding it in to dolly it was pretty pretty interesting what really like yeah given two sentences of somebody's description so can i know you're saying you don't have access to dolly how does someone get access to this do you know oh there you can see you click a link
to to like join their waitlist basically they're i think they're just one by one adding people okay and they also have some restrictions so they don't want you using it for uh kind of not safe for work type content. Oh, sure. Yeah, it makes sense. But yeah, so it works similar with GPT-3. Like I had applied for that and got some pretty early access. And that was also a really neat tool to play around with.
Wow, super cool. Yeah, so yeah, definitely folks should try this. Sign up for OpenAI. My guess is, definitely folks should try this, you know, sign up for OpenAI. My guess is, let me just try this out really quickly. I want to see if there's a thing where you can say you're a student. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. So you can kind of tell OpenAI, hey, I'm a student. Yeah, I just want to try this out. And that might bump you up on the list, or at least maybe they'll give you a free tier or something like that. But yeah, a ton of cool stuff you could do here. Definitely check it out. Yeah. So for my next one, I found this new story inside the longest Atlassian
outage of all time. So this was from pragmaticengineer.com. This is like, this is just a wild story. Yeah. So, so Atlassian, you know, makers of Jira, which is very central to many people's developer workflows, they had this downtime. So 40 customers lost access to Jira. And Atlassian didn't really put out an announcement or say anything. And 40 customers might not sound like a lot. But it turned out that the customers were of the size 50 000 to 800 000 users these were very large companies and yeah Atlassian wasn't saying anything but the I think they reached out individually to people at these companies but the companies are getting very nervous then they started talking about it on twitter this guy who runs the pragmatic engineer started talking about on twitter and then Atlassian kind of put out a statement but if you don't have your ticket tracking system like if it's just not available for going on days and days like it's very hard to get your job done right and there's a lot of important data in there like people are starting to worry like what's going on like have we lost
all of this information and it doesn't look good when the company doesn't get back to you at all right so so eventually they came out and they kind of said what happened do you any guesses what happened jason was it a dns issue sadly no so so they had i believe for they said for legal reasons which i think think means like GPDR, they have a script that removes customers. And there's two ways that it runs. One is like a soft delete, where it just kind of says, this customer's data is considered deleted, but it's still there. And then the other way for legal reasons is it actually deletes all the data from the database for that customer so they had run this script which i assume they run on like a nightly basis to clean up customers and it's the same script whether it
does the hard delete or the soft delete and it got run when it was supposed to be in soft delete mode like just hide the customers it got run in the hard delete mode where it actually blows all the data out of the database oh man so that's not good and then the the further thing that happened was it ran with the wrong set of customer ids i was going to say i mean why would you even blow away this huge customer yeah so like apparently not only did they run it wrong in hard delete mode, but they ran it with the wrong customer IDs. So they ended up deleting these 40 customers, probably intending to delete 40 other customers or soft delete them. They actually hard deleted these 40 very large customers. So then they had to come up with what to do from that point.
Turns out they back up all the data every day they do backups right but it took them a while to discover that this problem happened and in the meantime you know real customers are doing real things right so they can't just restore the backup from last night because every customer who's not the 40 customers who are down like they would all of a sudden lose all those you you know, data. Oh, cause they're all sharing the same database. Yeah, exactly. Oh, wow.
事实上，他们每天都在备份所有数据，而且确实在做备份，但他们花了很长时间才发现这个问题发生了，而在那期间，你知道的，真正的客户在做真实的操作，所以他们不能直接恢复昨晚的备份，因为除了那40个掉线的客户之外，其他所有客户都会突然失去所有那些，你知道的，数据。哦，因为他们都在共享同一个数据库。是的，完全正确。哦，天哪。
So yeah, so those were their options, right? Okay, we can restore, but then all these non-affected customers will lose data. Or what they ended up doing is like one by one, like restoring their data by like selectively inserting rows like i assume they stood up the they stood up a backup as like another database and like inserted records across like customer by customer which is why it took them nine days oh my gosh i love this part here it says they can't report the problem because they don't have a Jira account?
所以，是的，这就是他们的选择，对吧？好吧，我们可以恢复，但这样所有未受影响的客户都会失去数据。或者他们最终做的是逐个恢复数据，比如通过选择性地插入行，我猜他们把备份作为另一个数据库启动了，然后跨数据库逐个客户地插入记录，这就是为什么他们花了九天时间。哦，天哪，我喜欢这部分，这里说他们无法报告问题，因为他们没有Jira账户？
Oh, it's a crazy story. Like, I feel for them. Like, there's been a lot of backlash and people complaining about how horrible this is. But at the same time, like, I just feel bad for these people who had to man this issue or, you know. I guess even with GDPR, you can still have like a glacier, like a deep glacier backup, right? Because otherwise, the data would literally be gone. Oh, yeah, that's true. Yeah.
哦，这是一个疯狂的故事。真的，我很同情他们。你知道，有很多反对的声音，人们抱怨这有多糟糕。但与此同时，我也为那些不得不处理这个问题的人感到难过，或者，你知道的。我想即使有了GDPR，你仍然可以拥有像冰川存储那样的深度归档备份，对吧？因为否则，数据就会真的消失了。哦，是的，确实如此。是的。
Yeah. Oh, man, that is unbelievable. I mean, yeah, that if they had literally lost their data, because of that would have been really like a disastrous i mean at least this is uh they can recover from yeah but they that i think that they made an error by not talking about this like they kind of left everybody guessing for quite some time until you know this came out not by them but by people you know being scared and talking about it on hacker news and on twitter and stuff right right wow yeah this is an amazing story and i'm so glad you share this with me this is a wild ride folks should definitely uh check this out that is that's totally wild actually you know this reminds me of, did you hear about Fast, the company Fast? Yeah, yeah.
是的。哦，天哪，这太难以置信了。我的意思是，是的，如果他们真的因为这个而丢失了数据，那将真的是一场灾难。我的意思是，至少这是呃，他们可以从中学到经验恢复，但他们，我认为他们犯了一个错误，没有谈论这件事，他们有点让所有人猜测了相当长一段时间，直到，你知道的，这件事被曝光，不是由他们曝光的，而是人们，你知道的，感到恐慌并在Hacker News和Twitter等地方讨论它，对吧？对的，哇，是的，这是一个了不起的故事，我很高兴你和我分享这个，这是一次疯狂的经历，大家绝对应该呃看看这个，这真的是太疯狂了，实际上，你知道这让我想起了，你听说过Fast这家公司吗？对，对。
Oh my God. I mean, that is just unbelievable. So basically, okay, so this is a caveat. I mean, maybe we should have had a fifth news story here, but definitely people should do their own research. But what I believe I read was they were, I guess, like, you know, you could always kind of play with statistics. Right. So, for example, you could say, well, we have this many visits on our Web site, but it's not unique visits. So so, you know, then maybe like if somebody was or you could say I have this many calls to my Web site, but maybe it takes 10 calls to render the page, right? So there's all these games you can kind of play where you're saying things that are true, but you're misleading people at the same time, right? And so I think what was going on reading is kind of reading between the lines here is I think fast was, you know, giving out a bunch of statistics on their growth, which was looking really great, but they weren't using sort of these really core statistics that are
哦，天哪。我的意思是，这简直难以置信。所以基本上，好吧，所以这是一个警告。我的意思是，也许我们应该在这里加入第五条新闻，但人们绝对应该自己做调研。但我相信我读到的是，他们，我猜，你知道的，你总是可以玩弄统计数据。对。所以，例如，你可以说，嗯，我们的网站有这么多访问量，但它们不是独立访客。所以，你知道的，那么可能如果有人，或者你可以说我的网站有这么多调用，但渲染这个页面可能需要10次调用，对吧？所以有所有这些你可以玩的游戏，你说的话是真的，但同时又在误导人们，对吧？所以我想这里发生的事情，字里行间的意思是，我认为Fast当时，你知道的，公布了一堆关于他们增长的统计数据，看起来非常棒，但他们没有使用这些真正核心的统计数据，这些统计数据是
hard to fabricate, or these core metrics that are hard to fabricate or these core metrics that are hard to fabricate. And so at some point, I think it was a reporter. I don't know if this was leaked or if the reporter reverse engineered it. I think I've heard both stories now. But basically, a reporter wrote an article just proving beyond any doubt that on all the core metrics that matter, that FAST was more than an order of magnitude behind what everyone thought. Maybe two orders of magnitude or something. And so just to kind of explain it with an example,
很难捏造的，或者这些很难捏造的核心指标，或者这些很难捏造的核心指标。所以在某个时候，我认为是一个记者。我不知道这到底是泄露的还是记者逆向工程得出的。我想我现在听到了这两种说法。但基本上，记者写了一篇文章，无可辩驳地证明了在所有重要的核心指标上，FAST落后于所有人想象的程度超过了一个数量级。也许是两个数量级左右。所以为了用一个例子来解释它，
they had all this cloud infrastructure. They had a cloud infrastructure organization, but with the amount of traffic they were doing, they could have run it on one desktop. So that's the analogy that I was given. And that by itself is shocking, but that's not the most shocking part. The most shocking part was that within three days, the company shut down. And so there wasn't an acquisition. There wasn't like a hey, we're going to see you through this. There wasn't like we're
他们拥有所有这些云基础设施。他们有一个云基础设施组织，但以他们的流量，他们完全可以在一台台式机上运行它。这就是给我的类比。单凭这一点就令人震惊，但这还不是最让人震惊的部分。最令人震惊的部分是，在三天内，公司就倒闭了。所以没有收购。没有什么“嘿，我们会陪你度过难关”的说法。也没有什么“我们要”
going to turn the ship around. It wasn't like we work going to turn the ship around it wasn't like we work where eventually they got their feet back on the ground they just shut down and the only thing I can think of and you have obviously there's not a lot of information here the only thing I can think of is that you know the investors were just worried about lawsuits and the liability there and some of these things you know a lot of people don't know this but there's certain things you can do that will make you personally liable. Like I'll give you an example. You know, if you're involved in some kind of like really overt discrimination on the job, you could actually be held personally liable. So in other words, they can sue you as an individual separate from or in addition to suing your employer, right? That's an example of a thing
扭转乾坤的说法，也没有什么像我们工作那样，最终他们重新站稳脚跟，他们只是直接关门了。我能想到的唯一一件事，显然这里没有太多的信息，我能想到的唯一一件事就是，你知道的，投资者只是担心诉讼和其中的责任，其中有些事情，很多人都不知道，但有些事情你可以做，会让你承担个人责任。比如我举个例子。你知道，如果你参与了某种非常公开的工作歧视，你实际上可能会被追究个人责任。换句话说，他们可以把你作为个人起诉，独立于或者除了起诉你的雇主之外，对吧？这就是一个例子，
where like, even though you have an LLC, you know, under those conditions, the law has been designed so people can actually punch through the LLC and sue you directly. And so, you know, I think that some of these things around, you know, fraud are in that category. And so I think that was really the catalyst
即使你有一个有限责任公司，你知道，在这些条件下，法律的设计使得人们实际上可以穿透有限责任公司直接起诉你。所以，你知道，我认为围绕欺诈的一些事情就在那个范畴内。所以我想这才是真正催化剂
that made them just instantly, boom, shut down the whole company. And I mean that, and they were out of down the whole company and i mean that and they were out of money that definitely didn't help but they didn't try and look for a buyer or anything they completely shut down i have friends who worked there and you know yeah i feel for them you know obviously they're super talented that's a hot market so so they'll land on their feet but it was a huge shock that the people who work there had no idea oh wow yeah it really went down fast i think that it's hard if you're looking for new investors like people invest because they don't want to
让他们瞬间，轰的一声，关闭了整个公司。我的意思是，他们没钱了，这绝对没有帮助，但他们甚至没有试图寻找买家或什么的，他们完全关门了。我有朋友在那里工作，你知道，是的，我很同情他们，显然他们非常有才华，那是一个热门市场，所以他们会东山再起的，但这是一个巨大的震惊，在那里工作的人完全不知情。哦，哇，是的，它真的垮台得太快了，我觉得如果你在寻找新投资者的话这就很难，因为人们投资是因为他们不想
miss out on the new hot thing right and once your reputation has become tarnished like you're really you're not attractive yeah yeah totally i mean yeah, I mean, a lot of the engineers end up going to a company called Affirm. That is, you know, someone in a similar vertical. And I think under normal circumstances or ordinary circumstances, you know, there would have been some fire sale acquisition and some employees would have got, you know, some return on their stock and all of that. But yeah, this is just a wild story. And fortunately, it's extremely rare that something like that happens. Sponsor for today's show is Imparticle. At the end of the day, your customer has to be at the
错过新的热门事物，对吧？一旦你的声誉受损，你真的，你就没有吸引力了。是的，是的，完全同意。我的意思是，很多工程师最后去了一家叫Affirm的公司。那是，你知道的，在类似垂直领域的一家公司。而且我认为在正常情况下或普通情况下，你知道的，本会有某种贱卖收购，一些员工会得到，你知道的，他们股票的一些回报以及所有这些。但是，是的，这真的是一个疯狂的故事，幸运的是，发生那样的事情极其罕见。今天节目的赞助商是mParticle。归根结底，你的客户必须是你所做一切的
center of everything you do. This starts with the right customer data strategy, as well as the right foundation to solve the challenges that typically inhibit success, such as data quality, data governance, and connectivity. MParticle is your real-time customer data infrastructure that helps accelerate your data strategy by cleansing, visualizing, and integrating your customer data from anywhere to anywhere. Ultimately, better data leads to better decisions, better customer experiences, and better outcomes. Some of the best brands in retail, financial services, hospitality, media, travel, gaming,
核心。这始于正确的客户数据战略，以及解决通常阻碍成功的挑战的正确基础，例如数据质量、数据治理和连接性。mParticle是你的实时客户数据基础设施，它通过从任何地方到任何地方清洗、可视化和整合你的客户数据，帮助加速你的数据战略。归根结底，更好的数据带来更好的决策、更好的客户体验和更好的成果。零售、金融服务、酒店、媒体、旅游、游戏等领域的许多最佳品牌
and many other industries have chosen MParticle. Learn more by visiting www.mparticle.com. Better data, better decisions, better outcomes. Visit mparticle.com to learn how teams at Postmates, NBCUniversal, Spotify, and Airbnb use MParticle's customer data infrastructure to accelerate their customer data strategy. Cool. So on to book of the show my book of the show is actually a podcast but i've been uh listening to it neglecting my audible books and instead doing the podcast thing it's really fun
以及许多其他行业都选择了mParticle。访问 www.mparticle.com 了解更多信息。更好的数据，更好的决策，更好的成果。访问 mparticle.com，了解 Postmates、NBCUniversal、Spotify 和 Airbnb 的团队如何利用 mParticle 的客户数据基础设施来加速他们的客户数据战略。太好了。那么进入本期推荐书籍，我本期推荐的书实际上是一个播客，但我一直在听它，忽略了我的Audible有声书，转而听播客了，这真的很有趣
though it's the indie board game designers podcast and it's really fascinating i mean first you might even wonder how can that exist like how can someone make a board game you know on their own you know without a big budget or anything it turns out there's a ton of nice infrastructure there on the supply chain side and so as long as you're willing to stick with this canonical things you would find in a board game right like the punch out cardboard pieces and dice and as long as you don't anything too crazy you can get pretty much any board game design made relatively cheaply and so there's a bunch of indie board game designers who do this there's whole conventions and it's just fascinating the whole process think, is really fascinating. That's really cool.
不过，这是独立桌游设计师播客（The Indie Board Game Designers Podcast），这真的太吸引人了。首先，你甚至可能会好奇这怎么可能存在？比如怎么有人能制作一款桌游，你知道的，靠他们自己，你知道的，没有大预算什么的。事实上，在供应链方面有很多很好的基础设施，所以只要你愿意坚持在桌游中能找到的这些规范的东西，对吧？比如冲压的纸板零件和骰子，只要你没有什么太疯狂的想法，你几乎可以以相对便宜的价格让任何桌游设计变成现实。所以有一群独立桌游设计师就是这么做的，有整整各种会议，整个过程真的，我认为非常引人入胜。这真的很酷。
Yeah. So I picked for my book of the show, it's actually a series, but the series of books called The Laundry Files. And specifically, I just finished this one called Quantum of Nightmares. So this is a series of books by Charles Strauss. And it's hard to describe the genre they're in, but think if you like science fiction you'd probably like them so the laundry files is this series the concept of it is that like the right kind of like computer algorithms can like unlock some sort of demons from some other plane of the universe that's awesome yeah but the books are comedies so it's like a mixture of horror and like dilbert so in the very first book i read the atrocity archives like this guy is like
是的。所以我为本期节目挑选的书，实际上是一个系列，这个系列的书叫做《洗衣店档案》（The Laundry Files）。具体来说，我刚刚读完这本叫做《噩梦量子》（Quantum of Nightmares）的书。这是查尔斯·斯特罗斯（Charles Stross）的一系列图书。很难描述它们属于什么流派，但如果你喜欢科幻小说，你大概会喜欢它们。《洗衣店档案》就是这样一个系列，它的概念是，像正确的那种计算机算法可以从宇宙的另一个平面释放某种恶魔。这太棒了。是的，但这些书是喜剧，所以它有点像恐怖和呆伯特（Dilbert）的混合体。所以在读的第一本书《残暴档案》（The Atrocity Archives）里，这个家伙就像是
an it worker and he accidentally you know is doing some sort of combinatronics and summon some sort of demon and so it's a bit men in black style. Like there's the secret organization who comes and gets them and says like, listen, yes, demons are real and computer science is how you unleash them. And then like, yeah. So it's like the books often mix these genres together to humorous effect.
一个IT人员，他不小心，你知道的，做了一些组合数学，然后召唤了某种恶魔。所以它有点像《黑衣人》的风格。就像有一个神秘组织来找他们，说，听着，是的，恶魔是真实存在的，而计算机科学就是你释放它们的方式。然后就像，是的。所以这些书经常把这些流派混合在一起，达到幽默的效果。
So in the very first book, it's like, he is the it guy at this secret government agency. So he has to make sure the printers work, but also he has to like fight demons and yeah, very humorous and strange series of books. That is awesome. Yeah.
所以在第一本书中，就像，他是这个秘密政府机构的IT人员。所以他必须确保打印机正常工作，但同时他还必须与恶魔战斗，是的，非常幽默和奇怪的系列图书。这太棒了。是的。
There was a, there was a game for the Nintendo DS that was similar. Like you had, that was, it was had the same premise. Yeah. I think that's, that sounds awesome.
任天堂DS上有一款类似的游戏。就像你拥有的，那是一个，它有相同的设定。是的。我觉得这，听起来太棒了。
I'm definitely going to give this a read. I love stuff like that. Very cool. Is is it so you said it's three books are they like pretty heavy like roughly like how many pages like is this you know 20 30 hours audio or oh that's a good question so the laundry files is like a series i think there's probably like 12 books or something oh wow so i would pick the first one, which is called the Atrocity Archives. And the books themselves aren't massive, but there's a number of books. Ah, cool. Kind of like Terry Pratchett.
我一定要读一读。我喜欢这样的东西。非常酷。那是，你是说它是三本书，它们很厚吗？大致像有多少页？这是，你知道的，20到30小时的有声书吗？哦，这是个好问题。所以《洗衣店档案》就像是一个系列，我想大概有12本书左右吧。哦，哇。所以我会挑第一本，叫做《残暴档案》。书本身并不巨大，但有很多本。啊，酷。有点像特里·普拉切特（Terry Pratchett）。
Yeah, yeah. Definitely some similar vibes, I would say. Yeah. Oh, very cool. Yeah, that is awesome. Cool. And if you want to listen to that or Terry Pratchett, you can check both of those out on Audible. Audible is a lot of fun. I actually just,
是的，是的。我想肯定有一些类似的氛围。是的。哦，非常酷。是的，这太棒了。太好了。如果你想听那个或特里·普拉切特的书，你可以在Audible上查看这两本。Audible非常有趣。我其实刚刚，
I don't know at what point I switched over, but I have the thing now where you pay once a year and you get all your credits up front. And so I just rolled over. So I have 12 credits to spend and yeah, I still have about three or four books to finish up. So a little bit behind, but, but overall, I love it. I mean, especially if you go for a run or go for a hike and you can download the book so you don't have to worry about blowing through all of your internet on your cell phone device and everything. So check out Audible. And if you want to check out Audible, you can go to audibletrial.com slash programming
我不知道我在哪个时间点切换过来的，但我现在有这样的模式：每年付一次费，然后你就能预先获得所有的积分。所以我刚刚续期了。所以我手里有12个积分可以花，是的，我还有大约三四本书要读完。所以有点落后，但总的来说，我非常喜欢。我的意思是，特别是如果你去跑步或徒步旅行，你可以下载这些书，这样你就不用担心耗尽你手机上的所有流量了。所以去看看Audible吧。如果你想查看Audible，你可以去 audibletrial.com/programming
throw down. That helps us out. If you want to help us out and you already have Audible or you don't want to get Audible, you can check us out on Patreon. So that's patreon.com slash programming throwdown. And with that, it's time for tool of the show. My tool of the show is Zapier. And so Zapier is a like internet workflow automation platform, I guess if I had to describe it in one line, what it does is it lets you connect things and automate things that involve, you know, common services on the internet. So for example, you might say, if I if someone sets up a calendar invite with me so if i get any new calendar
throw down。这能帮到我们。如果你想帮我们，而且你已经有了Audible或者你不想买Audible，你可以在Patreon上关注我们。网址是 patreon.com/programming throwdown。接下来是本期推荐工具。我本期推荐的工具是Zapier。Zapier是一个互联网工作流自动化平台，我想如果必须用一句话来描述它的功能，那就是它允许你连接不同的东西，并自动化涉及互联网上常见服务的任务。例如，你可以说，如果有人与我建立日历邀请，所以如果我的Google日历上有任何新的日历
meetings on my google calendar then send me a text message right or you might say something like when i email this special address at zapier i want zapier to take the subject line and create a calendar meeting from it right um there's all sorts of things you can do zapier kind of lets you connect all these things together i found an open source one called n8n which i thought was really interesting i guess what would that be natan i don't know but i actually found zapier to be pretty generous they give you i think it's like a thousand triggers so you can trigger something a thousand times a month before you have to start paying anything. I'm well below that. And overall, I thought the experience was great. It was really solid and I've used it to streamline
会议，就给我发一条短信，对吧？或者你可能会说，当我向Zapier的这个特殊地址发送电子邮件时，我希望Zapier获取主题行并从中创建一个日历会议，对吧？嗯，你可以做各种各样的事情，Zapier基本上让你把所有这些东西连接在一起。我发现了一个开源的替代品叫n8n，我觉得这真的很有趣。我想那是什么，n8n？我不知道，但我实际上发现Zapier相当慷慨，他们提供，我想大约是一千个触发器，所以你可以在必须开始付费之前，每个月触发某事一千次。远低于这个数量。总的来说，我觉得体验非常棒。它非常坚实，我用它来简化
a lot of different processes. So I've been really digging that. Very cool. Yeah. I've used it for things here and there. It definitely has that kind of flow chart coding feel to it, but it's cool the things you can hook up to it yeah totally i mean the big thing is it's uh it's totally serverless i mean it's you know it's on their their network so you don't need a computer you know running cron you know running 24 7 and all that they handle all the infrastructure for you so for my tool this is a totally bias picked but i'm going to choose i'm going to choose earthly which is an open source tool and also a company uh that employs me so so bias be noted there but so earthly is a a build tool that that tries to bring together these ideas of both building software and continuous integration. So Earthly uses containers
许多不同的流程。所以我真的很喜欢它。非常酷。是的。我在这里和那里用过它几次。它确实有那种流程图编码的感觉，但你能用它连接的东西真的很酷。完全同意，我的意思是最大的一点是它是完全无服务器的。我的意思是，你知道它在他们的网络上，所以你不需要一台运行cron、24/7全天候运行的计算机，他们为你处理所有的基础设施。所以对于我的工具，这是一个完全有偏见的挑选，但我将选择，我将选择Earthly，这是一个开源工具，也是一家雇佣我的公司。所以请注意这里的偏见。Earthly是一个构建工具，它试图将构建软件和持续集成（CI）这两个概念结合在一起。Earthly使用容器
like as in Docker containers to build your software. And it has a format that is kind of a mix of a make file and a Docker file. And so you can specify how you would build, you know, your software inside this format. And then, you know, the feature that often brings people to Earthly is then you can run your CI build on your local machine, or you can run it in Jenkins or in GitHub actions, or whatever you happen to be using. So yeah, the thing that we're really excited about is just, you know, making builds, and CI like, like code and something that you can run on your local environment that you don't have to like put in little commits that says like oh hopefully this will get the build working and then push that and so it's a really cool tool at least from my perspective and yeah i'll have to
就像Docker容器一样来构建你的软件。它有一种格式，有点像Makefile和Dockerfile的混合体。因此，你可以在这种格式中指定如何构建你的软件。然后，你知道，通常把人们吸引到Earthly的功能是，你可以在本地机器上运行你的CI构建，或者你可以在Jenkins或GitHub Actions中运行它，或者无论你碰巧在使用的什么。所以，是的，我们真正感到兴奋的是，只是，你知道的，使构建和CI就像代码一样，并且是那种你可以在本地环境中运行的东西，而不必像提交一些小改动那样说“哦，希望这能让构建工作正常”，然后推送它。所以这是一个非常酷的工具，至少从我的角度来看是这样，是的，我得
i'll have to check that out because i if you look at the eternal terminal repo you'll find a ton of these commits that are like maybe this will work maybe that'll work maybe this will work and they're all commits where i using the github website you know you can edit single files and yeah yeah so it's all done through that and i tried some homebrew thing that was like a local github actions oh yeah where yeah i tried it and you know it just didn't work and i just i think maybe I needed to be on Linux and I was doing this on my MacBook, but I feel like it either works or it doesn't. If it doesn't work, it's not a thing I could easily debug.
我得去看看，因为如果你看一下永恒终端（Eternal Terminal）的代码仓库，你会发现大量这样的提交，比如“也许这会管用”、“也许那个会管用”、“也许这个会管用”，而且这些都是我使用GitHub网站（你知道的，你可以编辑单个文件）进行的提交，是的，是的，所以这一切都是通过这种方式完成的。我尝试了一些Homebrew的东西，就像本地的GitHub Actions一样，哦，是的，在那里，是的，我试过了，你知道，它就是不工作，然后我只是，我想我可能需要在Linux上运行，而我是在MacBook上做这件事的，但我觉得它要么管用，要么不管用。如果不管用，这不是一个我可以轻易调试的东西。
And so this is a real problem. Yeah, I know I've personally had it. So yeah, I'll have to check that out. So what is Earthly's, like, do you sign up or how does it work? Is it a thing you download yeah so go to earthly.dev and you can follow the links to download there you can also find it on on github and so yeah it's a command line tool and yeah so you write you kind of write your build in the
所以这是一个真正的问题。是的，我知道我自己遇到过。所以，是的，我得去看看。那么Earthly是怎样的，比如，你需要注册吗？它是怎么运作的？这是一个你可以下载的东西吗？是的，去 earthly.dev，你可以按照那里的链接下载，你也可以在GitHub上找到它。所以，是的，它是一个命令行工具，是的，你有点像在
earth file format and then you can call earthly from within github actions or within jenkins or or whatever and also on your local so to provide some backstory so so vlad who created earthly he he worked at google and google has like internally a blaze i believe is their build system and then it was open sourced as basil or they made something similar that's open source i don't know the exact history there. Yeah, I think it's like a fork, but yeah, you have the right idea. Yeah, so Vlad wanted a tool like that,
Earth文件格式中编写你的构建，然后你可以在GitHub Actions或Jenkins中调用Earthly，或者无论什么，也可以在本地调用。所以为了提供一些背景信息，创建Earthly的Vlad曾在谷歌工作，谷歌内部有一个叫Blaze的构建系统，我相信是这样，然后它被开源为Bazel，或者他们做了一个类似的开源项目，我不知道确切的历史。是的，我i觉得它就像是一个分支，但你的想法是对的。是的，所以Vlad想要一个那样的工具，
but that was easier to use. Like Bazel is known to be really amazing if you have like a platform engineering team who can set up like distributed builds and get everything working. And if you use a monorepo and the type of languages that Google uses, it can be really powerful. But for everybody else, it's really a big hurdle to overcome. So Vlad built Earthly as kind of a middle ground between something like
但用起来更简单。比如Bazel以非常棒著称，如果你有一个平台工程团队，能够设置分布式构建并使一切正常工作的话。如果你使用单一代码仓库（monorepo）和谷歌使用的那种语言，它会非常强大。但对其他人来说，这真的是一个很难克服的障碍。所以Vlad构建Earthly作为类似Bazel和GitHub Action之间的中间地带。因此它允许你，你知道的，内置缓存并并行执行任务。但它也有一个非常棒、使用简单的格式。你知道的，你不需要使用单一代码仓库。你可以使用你已经在使用的工具。如果你使用NPM构建某些东西，你可以在Earthly中使用它。如果你已经在用Jenkins，你可以在Jenkins内部使用Earthly。所以这就是它背后的背景故事。是的，你可以在GitHub Actions上找到它，或者你只需要运行brew install，我想
Bazel and something like GitHub Action. So it allows you to, you know, have caching built in and to kind of do things in parallel. But it also has like a really nice, simple to use format. You know, you don't have to use a monorepo. You can use the tools you already use. If you're using NPM to build something, you can use that in Earthly. If you're already using Jenkins, you can use Earthly inside Jenkins. Yeah, so that's kind of the backstory behind it. And yeah, you can find it on GitHub Act actions or you can just do brew install i think
应该是 brew install earthly，出于某种奇怪的原因，挺好的。但去 earthly.dev 看看吧。所以Earthly不是在运行你的CI，对吧？你的CI仍然在GitHub Actions上运行，只是Earthly在协助它。完全正确，是的，你会编写一个类似于Makefile的Earth文件，但有一些改进，使其容器化并行运行，然后它仍然会在GitHub Actions中运行，但它是通过Earthly命令行工具在GitHub Actions中运行的。明白了，明白了，酷，是的，我得去看看。那会很棒的。这实际上很好地过渡到了我们的主题，即开源项目的资金支持。你知道的，我一直很好奇的一件事，特别是当我还在高中和大学的时候，我想知道像Linux这样庞大的项目，你知道，这个庞大的群体，社区是如何协调的，人们是如何，你知道的，运行这样一个大项目需要大量的资源。然后还有，你知道的，如果我们，你知道的，如果这些公司决定具有企业精神，你知道的，他们如何赚钱，以及那些把一切都投入到开源中的人，他们是如何，他们是如何不失去他们所有的知识产权的？这些事情总是非常迷人，我虽然现在没有所有的答案，但我已经花了多年时间
it's brew install earthly for some strange reason nice but yeah go to earthly.dev so earthly isn't like running your ci right you're still the ci is still running on github actions it's just earthly is facilitating that that's right yeah you would write an earth file that is similar to a make file but with some improvements such that it's containerized and runs in parallel and then you it would still run in get up actions but it would be running in get up actions via earthly command line tool got it got it cool yeah i'll have to check that out. That'd be nice. So that gets actually a good segue to our topic, which is funding open source projects. And you know, it's one thing that I always wondered, you know, especially when I was in high school and in college, I was wondering, like, these massive projects like Linux, you know, how do you how does this massive group, you know, community coordinate and how do people, you know, it costs a lot of resources to run a big project like that. And then also, you know, if we, you know, if these companies decide to be enterprising, you know, how can they make money and how do people who have sort of put everything in open source, how did they sort of, how did they not just lose all their intellectual property? And these things are always really fascinating and i definitely don't have all the answers now but i've spent many years
在这个生态系统中，亚当我知道你也是，我们现在对这一切是如何运作的有了相当好的理解。所以我想如果你正在外面，你知道的，你在构建某种工具，你对工具感兴趣，或者你只是在使用大量的开源，我认为这可以，你知道的，回答很多那些问题。是的，这是一个超级吸引人的领域。特别是如果你也在想，嘿，我正在构建一个开源工具。如果这是一件我能获得报酬的事情，那就太好了，
kind of in this ecosystem i know you have two adam and we have a pretty good understanding now of how how that all works and so i think if you're out there you know and you're building kind of tools you're interested in tools or you're just using a lot of open source and i think that this can you know answer a lot of those a lot of I think that this can answer a lot of those questions. Yeah, it's a super fascinating area. And especially also if you're just thinking like, hey, I'm building an open source tool. And I would love if this were something I was paid to do,
或者如果我至少能得到足够的报酬，让它不仅仅是我必须做的事情，或者仅仅是在周末让我忙碌的事情。是的，确实如此。就像那个古代艺术家的困境，你知道的，就像，我怎么能练习我的手艺或者做那件我认为是我的核心优势、我真正喜欢的事情，同时也能维持生计呢？所以，完全免责声明，你知道的，如果你有一个开源项目，你不一定非得赚钱。我的意思是永恒终端（Eternal Terminal）赚了零美元，我确实放了一个捐赠链接，但我没有宣传它或什么的，所以，是的，不出所料，永恒终端从来没有赚过哪怕一美元，对我来说这没问题。所以，我们并不是在这里说开源
or if I were at least remunerated enough to make it more than just something that I have to do or that keeps me busy on the weekends. Yeah, that's true. It's like that um ancient you know artist dilemma yeah like like how can i practice my craft or do that thing that i is my sort of core strength that i really love and you know also be able to sustain money yeah so you know full disclaimer you know you don't have to make money you know if you have an open source project i mean eternal terminal makes zero dollars and i did put a donations link but i didn't promote it or anything and so yeah unsurprisingly eternal terminal has never made even a dollar and that for me is fine so you know we're not saying here that open source
项目需要资金支持，或者有资金支持的项目就更好，诸如此类。这里没有任何价值判断。我们要解释的是那些有资金支持的项目是如何做到这一点的。是的，这说得通。是的，所以我想，正如我开始时所说的那样，捐赠真的很难获得。有一篇很有意思的Medium文章，我们会在节目注释中链接它。标题是“GitHub星星付不起你的房租”（GitHub stars won't pay your rent），我觉得这是一个很生动的说法。但从高层次来看，这个人的观点（我绝对同意）是，如果你在那里放一个捐赠页面，有时甚至在自述文件（README）中，
projects need to be funded or that they're better you know ones that are funded are better any anything like there's no value judgment here what we are going to explain is the ones that are funded how do they go about doing that yeah that makes sense yeah so so i guess you know as i kind of started off here donations are really difficult to get right. I think there's this interesting Medium article, which we'll link to in the show notes. The title is GitHub stars won't pay your rent, which I think is a cute way of saying it. But at a high level, what this person is saying, which I definitely can agree with is, you know, if you put a donation page there, sometimes even if you in the read me,
你指向了捐赠按钮及所有这些，你知道的，人们捐款通常是不够的，对吧？我认为，你需要做更多的事情。我不认为你必须提供任何实际的物质东西，但显然只在你的自述文件里告诉人们捐款是远远不够的。这个人比我做得好得多，真正深入探讨了细节。他们在如何将自己的代码库货币化方面花费了大量的时间和精力，但捐赠对他们来说确实不管用。不过亚当，你找到了几个确实管用的地方。是的，所以有两个我真的很尊敬的项目，一个是Serenity OS，
you kind of point up to the donations button and everything, you know, it's generally not enough, you know, for people to donate, right? I think that, you know, you need to do something more. I don't think you have to provide anything material, but clearly just telling people to donate on your read me isn't going to be enough. And this person does a much better job than I could kind of really diving into details. They spent a ton of time and energy on how to, you know, how to monetize their repository and donations just didn't work for them. But Adam, you found a couple of places where it did work. Yeah, so two projects that I actually really look up to, like one is Serenity OS and the
另一个是Zig编程语言。这两个项目背后的幕后推手都成功地为他们的开源项目建立了足够的支持，以支持他们全职开发。他们采取的方法挺有意思的。所以创建Zig的安德鲁·凯利（Andrew Kelly），他围绕自己和这门语言建立了一个社区。他写博客谈论它。他谈论它，直播自己构建它的过程，并在直播时请求捐赠。所以，你知道的，他的关键几乎就像是一个网红，但却是针对开发者的，就像是，这就是我如何构建一门编程语言。他还向人们讲述了很多关于他希望余生都致力于此并构建这个真正令人惊叹的编程
other one is the Zig programming language. And so both the people behind these have managed to build up enough support of their open source projects to support themselves full time. And it's kind of interesting the way that they approach that. So Andrew Kelly, who created Zig, you know, he built a community around himself and this language. He blogged about it. He talked about it. He streamed himself building it and he asked for donations when he streamed it. So, you know, a little bit, his key was almost becoming like a, like an influencer, but for developers, like, here's how I'm building a programming language. And he also talked a lot, you know, to people about how he wanted to work on this for the rest of his life and build this really amazing programming
语言的愿望。我认为这激励了人们说，你知道的，我，你知道的，我是那种很乐意看到有人能这样追求自己激情的人。因此，他得以辞掉工作，全职致力于Zig。Serenity OS是一个类似的项目，由安德烈亚斯·克林（Andreas Kling）发起，他曾在苹果工作，然后离开苹果去开发Serenity OS，这是一个他完全从零开始构建的操作系统，他在YouTube上直播这个过程，并建立了足够的支持者来养活他。现在对于这两个项目来说，它现在已经不仅仅是他们两个人了，有其他人加入了进来。是的，我认为最大的教训是，你需要建立一个社区，你需要使用Patreon，你需要告诉人们，你知道的，我希望得到你们的
language. And I think that inspired people to say like, you know, I, you know, I'm the type of person who would, I would love to see somebody who can pursue their passion like that. And so he, he was able to leave his job to, to work on Zig full time. And Serenity OS is a similar project by Andreas Kling, who worked at Apple and then left Apple to work on this Serenity OS, which is operating system he's, you know, he was building totally from scratch, streaming himself on YouTube, doing that, and built up enough supporters that it's supporting him. And now for both of these projects, it's now bigger than just the two of them, they have had other people join and yeah i think the big lesson is that you need to you know build up a community you need to use patreon you need to tell people you know i i would like your
支持，这将帮助我继续构建这个项目。我认为这是一个新想法，对吧？这并不是，我想用什么词来着，就像在软件领域建立一个社区来支持你，这是一种有趣的全新方法。是的，完全同意。我认为，是的，我认为我们在其他艺术形式中也见过这种情况，对吧？所以你会看到，我们去，我们每年在市中心都有一个当地的艺术品和手工艺品集市，你知道的。所以我们会去那里，
support that will help me continue to build this and i think this is a new idea right like this isn't what's the word i want like like building up a community to support you like this in software is kind of an interesting new way to approach things. Yeah, totally. I think that, yeah, I think that we've seen this in other art forms, right? So you see, like we go to the, we have a local kind of arts and crafts fair that happens once a year, you know, in downtown. And so we'll go there and
那里会有一群当地艺术家在创作东西。有一次我们从一位女士那里买了一幅画。她给了我们她的名片，然后我们需要在不同的房间里摆放类似风格的东西。所以这些人成为了这个本地社区的一部分。他们建立了这个社区活动。因此他们能够组织并启动这种声誉，对吧？所以我们去那里是因为我们觉得有机会看到一些非常有趣的东西，你从中得到的是一种关系，你看到了这个人，你与他们互动，然后你可以把他们的一部分努力成果带回家。当你看到它时，你会把那幅画与这个人联系起来，你会想象他们在上面工作的情景，所以感觉你真的为真实的事情做出了贡献，所以你觉得你确实从中得到了收获，相比之下，如果你只是放一个捐赠按钮，那么很难让人真正觉得他们做出了贡献，或者他们不一定知道他们的钱去哪了，或者谁是那个工作的人，或者这是否是这个人已经放弃的东西，所以你的钱实际上并没有为你换回任何东西，对吧？所以，是的，正如你所说，拥有那个Patreon并与你的社区进行持续的对话是一种抵押品，你知道你将长期坚持下去，他们也确实在支持你和你的激情。我觉得，从某种程度上讲，这是资助创意工作最古老的方法，就像我认为达芬奇，你知道的，有国王作为他的赞助商付钱让他创作东西，就像你可以向Programming Throwdown的Patreon捐款一样，人们支持达芬奇、米开朗基罗等等。是的，这是一个非常好的比喻，完全正确。那么你在这里发布的这个链接是什么？oss.cash，这是一个很短的链接，我喜欢。是的，因为我为一家开源开发工具公司工作，我想其中一位风投分享了这个给我们。这是所有估值超过1亿美元的开源公司的列表。
there'll be a bunch of local artists creating things. And one time we bought a painting from this lady. She gave us her business card and then we needed a similar kind of thing in a different room. And so these people become part of this local community. They set up this community event. And so they are able to kind of organize and bootstrap you know this reputation right so so we went there because we thought there was a chance there's going to be some really interesting stuff and so what you're getting out of that is you're getting kind of a relationship you're seeing the person you're interacting with and then you get to take a piece of their kind of effort home and and when you see it you kind of can connect that painting that you see
会有很多本地艺术家创作各种作品。有一次我们从一位女士那里买了一幅画。她给了我们她的名片，后来我们在另一个房间也需要类似的东西。于是这些人成了这个本地社区的一部分。他们举办了这个社区活动。因此他们能够组织并建立起这种声誉，对吧？所以我们去了那里，因为我们觉得可能会有一些非常有趣的东西，你从中得到的是一种关系，你看到了这个人，与他们互动，然后你可以把他们的一种心血带回家，当你看到它时，你就能把看到的这幅画联系起来
with this person you kind of imagine them kind of working on it and so it feels like you really contributed to something real and so you feel like like you actually get something out of it versus if you just put a donation button then it's hard for somebody to really feel like they really contributed or they don't know necessarily where their money's going or who's the person working on it or is this like something that the person has abandoned and so your money is not actually going to get you anything right and so so yeah to your point you're having that patreon and having that constant discourse with your community is a collateral that you know you're in this for the long call and that they're you know
和这个人联系起来，你会想象他们创作时的情景，所以你会觉得你真的为某些真实的事情做出了贡献，你会觉得你确实从中得到了什么，而如果你只是放一个捐赠按钮，那么别人很难真正觉得他们做出了贡献，或者他们不一定知道他们的钱去了哪里，是谁在创作，或者这是否是这个人已经放弃的东西，所以你的钱实际上并不能给你带来任何东西，对吧？所以，正如你所说，拥有Patreon并与你的社区保持持续的交流，这是一种担保，你知道你是为了长远的发展，而他们，你知道的
really supporting you and your passion and i feel like it i mean in some ways it's the oldest method of funding creative endeavors like i think da vinci was you know there were kings that that were his patrons that paid him to to create things just the same way that you know you can donate to the programming throwdown patreon you know people supported da vinci and michelangelo and etc yeah yeah it's a really good analogy exactly right so what is this link you posted a link here oss.cash it's a very short link i like it yeah so um working for as i do for a open source dev tool company i think one of the venture capitalists shared this with us so this is a list of all of the companies with like a value of over 100 million dollars that are open source And so the business models have changed over time, like the very first
随着时间的推移，商业模式已经发生了变化，第一家变得如此巨大的开源公司是红帽（Red Hat）。红帽的模式是收取支持费用。所以你要为支持和维护付费以获得像RHEL（红帽企业Linux）这样的产品，但是这些模式，我不知道，我应该直接跳到讨论那篇文章吗？是的，我们就这么做吧。是的。所以红帽，那是他们的模式，他们凭借支持模式变成了一家非常大的公司。但如果你跟那些资助开源业务的投资者交谈，他们会认为支持模式有点像个失败，只有红帽真正把它做成功了。还有相当多的公司尝试过，红帽，你知道的，
open source company to get that large was Red Hat. And Red Hat's model was charging for support. So you would pay for support and maintenance to get like RHEL, like Red Hat Linux, but the models, I don't know, should I jump to talking about that article? Yeah, let's just do it. Yeah. Yeah. So Red Hat, that was their model, they became a very large company with the support model. But if you talk to the type of investors who fund open source businesses, they would consider the support model to be sort of a failure, like only Red Hat really made it work. And there was like a whole number of companies that tried and red hat you know
也不是那么壮观地成功。是的，我记得，我记得随口说一下，我记得当Optimizely转向支持模型时。所以Optimizely过去基本上按点击付费，或者按，你知道的，这是一种产品，然后你要支付增量费用，但你基本上是在为产品付费。然后我猜，你知道，那里没有足够的产品。但出于某种原因，他们转向了Optimizely X，它有点像支持类型的系统，如果你对如何设计优化有困难，你可以去找他们，对我来说，这印证了你刚才所说的话，对我来说，这是一个它处于不佳状态的信号，然后他们，我想Optimizely后来被收购了，我不记得是被谁收购了，我现在查一下。但正如你所说，当公司走“我们将支持这个软件，这就是我们所有人如何获得报酬”的路线时。似乎这在实践中从来没有真正起作用过。这篇文章很好地解释了原因。是的，这是一个很难让其奏效的模式。就像这是真的，好吧，我有产品，我开源它，大公司在使用它。我是世界上最适合为他们提供支持的人。但这并不能真正扩展成为一项大业务，对吧？这只是希望企业会因为使用了你免费制作的东西而付钱给你。是的，这
also wasn't spectacularly successful yeah i remember i remember just riffing on that i remember when optimizely went to a support model so optimizely used to charge basically i think it was per click or per you know it's a product, then you'd pay an incremental fee, but you're basically paying for the product. And then I guess, you know, there wasn't just enough product there. But for some reason, they switched to optimize the X, where it was sort of a support type system where if you had trouble with your how to design your optimization, you would go to them and that actually to me it's a double click on what you're saying that to me was a sign that it wasn't in a
也不是特别成功。是的，我记得，我记得顺着这个话题说下去，我记得当Optimizely转向支持模式的时候，Optimizely过去收费基本上是按点击量或者按你懂的，这是一个产品，然后你会支付增量费用，但你基本上是为产品付费。然后我猜，你知道，那里没有足够的产品。但出于某种原因，他们转向了Optimize the X，这有点像一种支持类型的系统，如果你在如何设计优化方面遇到麻烦，你可以去找他们，对我来说，这印证了你刚才所说的话，对我来说，这是一种信号，说明它不在
good place and then they i think optimizely sold later on they got acquired i don't remember by who i'll look it up right now but to your point it seems like when companies go the you know we'll support this software and that's how we'll all get paid. It seems like that never actually works in practice. This article does a really good job explaining why. Yeah, it's a hard model to make work. Like it is true. Like, okay, I have a product, I open source it, big companies are using it. I'm the best person in the world to offer them support. But like that doesn't really scale into becoming a big business right that's just hoping that businesses will pay you because they use something you've made for free yeah it's
是在拿他们当人质，对吧？就像你知道的，你随时都可以扔下一颗毒丸，然后强迫这些人接受你的支持，你知道的，从经济学角度来看，这是一个非常奇怪的动态。是的，这也是一个奇怪的动态，因为那些大公司可以对你拥有很大的权力，对吧？我不知道，就像他们可能会有一个功能因为你的开源产品而被阻止，并且要求很高。对的，这说得通。所以Episerver是收购Optimizely的公司，而Episerver我没听说过，所以它并不是被谷歌之类的大公司或什么巨头收购的。所以，是的，我认为，正如你所说，如果你要提供高级支持，你还不如一不做二不休，直接弄一个单独的高级版本。
holding them hostage right it's like you know like you at any point you could kind of drop a poison pill and then force those people to get on your support you know it's kind of it's a really weird dynamic economically yeah and it's a weird dynamic also just because those big companies can have a lot of power over you right like i don't know like they they could have a they could have a feature that's being blocked because of your open source product and be very demanding right right that makes sense so epi server is the company that acquired optimizely which epi servers i haven't heard of it so it's not like they got acquired by google or something that is a massive like fang company or something so so yeah i think yeah and to your point you know if you're going to have premium support you might as well go all the way and just have a separate premium version
把他们当人质，对吧？就像你知道的，你随时都可以丢下一个毒丸，然后迫使这些人来寻求你的支持，你知道的，这在经济上是一种非常奇怪的动态。是的，这也是一种奇怪的动态，因为那些大公司对你拥有很大的权力，对吧？比如，我不知道，他们可能会因为你的开源产品而阻止某个功能的发布，并且要求非常严格。对，这说得通。所以Epi Server是收购了Optimizely的公司，而Epi Server我没听说过，所以这不像是被谷歌或其他大型科技公司收购了，那可是像FANG那样的大公司。所以，是的，我认为，正如你所说，如果你要提供高级支持，你不如索性一路到底，直接出一个单独的高级版本
of your software, right? Because at the end of the day, the support is going to translate into new features that company needs. So why not just make an enterprise version? And I think that model tends to work much better. Yeah, I think like that's one of the models you see more commonly today, I guess is what is like what they call open core model, right? A core product that is open source, and then certain differentiating things that large companies might want would pay for. So I have a friend who works at Mattermost, which is like a Slack open source alternative to Slack or discord and my understanding is they like it's an open source product but if you want to have like single sign-on using like saml or open id or the types of
你的软件，对吧？因为归根结底，这些支持将转化为公司所需的新功能。那为什么不直接做一个企业版呢？而且我认为这种模式往往运作得更好。是的，我认为这可以说是你今天看到更普遍的模式之一，也就是所谓的“开放核心”模式，对吧？一个开源的核心产品，然后是大型公司可能会需要并愿意付费的某些差异化功能。所以我有个朋友在 Mattermost 工作，它就像是 Slack 的开源替代品，或者是类似 Discord 的产品，据我了解，它是开源的，但如果你想要单点登录（比如使用 SAML 或 OpenID），或者诸如之类的大公司所要求并愿意付费的功能，
features that you know a large company demands and will pay for then those are premium features so that's like open core as they call that yeah exactly and i think that works pretty well i think i mean that's been going all the way back to visual studio right i mean visual studio had the the student edition which i mean well actually we should talk about that as well so in addition to paying for extra functionality there's sometimes where the you're paying for the license so yeah so i think as a student now you can get you know the full visual studio but you're paying for the license. So I think as a student now, you can get the full Visual Studio, but you're not licensed to run a business that makes a certain amount of revenue with that software. At that point, you have to pay money to get the appropriate license. there's feature parity there but it's technically i guess illegal or i guess civilly like illegal to to to run that to run a business off the virtual box without paying for a business license but oh yeah but visual studio used to have like a student edition which was really pared down
那么这些就是高级功能，所以这就是他们所说的开放核心，是的，完全正确。而且我认为这效果相当不错，我的意思是，这可以一直追溯到 Visual Studio，对吧？我的意思是 Visual Studio 曾有学生版，其实我们也可以讨论一下这个，所以除了为额外功能付费之外，有时你实际上是在为许可证付费，所以，是的，我认为作为一个现在的学生，你可以获得完整的 Visual Studio，但你是在为许可证付费。因此，我认为作为一个现在的学生，你可以获得完整的 Visual Studio，但你没有获得使用该软件运行产生一定收入的业务的许可证。在那个时候，你必须花钱购买相应的许可证。
and so if you wanted the professional edition then you would have to you know pay microsoft and you get all these extra features so even in the 90s this was a thing and it's interesting because like you know what is the difference between something that's open source and something that's free i mean they are different right so like that's a good point i believe right visual studio has free editions but it's not open source yep yep yeah you're totally right so yeah they had the whole i guess yeah that's more like a freemium model than an open core model so those are two different things and like my understanding is like for a lot of developer tools developers have kind of come to expect that things are open source and especially one reason for that is that maybe if you hit a limitation and
其中的功能是一样的，但从技术上讲，我想这是非法的，或者在民事上来说，运行没有为商业许可证付费的 Virtual Box 业务是非法的，不过，哦，是的，但 Visual Studio 过去曾有一个删减很多的学生版，所以如果你想要专业版，那么你就必须付费给微软，然后你就能获得所有这些额外功能，因此即使在 90 年代这也是存在的，这很有趣，因为像开源和免费有什么区别，我的意思是它们是不同的，对吧？所以这是一个很好的观点，我相信，对吧？Visual Studio 有免费版本，但它不是开源的。是的，是的，你说得完全对。
you're really locked in to this ecosystem that you might be able to add that feature, right? By being having access to the source, you might be able to add things you need. Also, you can kind of inspect it if you're like, hey, this is something that stores the secrets in my organization. Like you might really want it to be something non proprietary that you can look through and make sure it doesn't like curl somebody's password off to some URL or something like that. So there can be security reasons why people might want something to be a very least like source available, like you could see the source. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, I mean, other things that companies will pay for that individuals
所以，是的，他们有整个，我想是的，这更像是一个免费增值模式，而不是开放核心模式，所以这是两个不同的事情。据我了解，对于许多开发人员工具，开发人员已经习惯了开源，其中一个原因可能是，如果你遇到了局限性，并且你真的被锁定在这个生态系统中，你或许能够添加该功能，对吧？通过访问源代码，你或许能够添加你需要的东西。此外，如果你想说，“嘿，这是在我的组织中存储机密的东西”，你也可以对其进行检查。就像你可能真的希望它不是专有的，你可以通读它并确保它不会把某个人的密码用 curl 发送到某个 URL 或类似的地方。因此，出于安全原因，人们可能希望某些东西至少是源码可用的，比如你可以看到源码。是的，这说得通。
wouldn't really get a lot of value out of our, as you said, like security and auditing. So there's a good example of this is Century. So Century, interestingly, I'll tell you the history of Century was started by one, I forgot the person's name, but he was working at a startup. And he wanted to catch crashes, and then also catch breadcrumbs and look at performance monitoring and all these things. And some of these things, I mean, you can kind of piecemeal it together. So you can use open telemetry for the performance monitoring. There's like roll bar and some of these things for catching crashes on your crash reporter. But there wasn't really one solution that did it all and had a really nice interface people would have to then put their crashes into data dog and use data dogs like pattern finding right because you can imagine you might get back 10 000 crashes and it's all basically the same issue just with you know i expected 32 but i got but I got 16. I expected 30 or I expected,
是的，我的意思是，公司会为之付费而个人无法从中获得太多价值的其他东西是，正如你所说，安全和审计。所以Sentry就是一个很好的例子。有趣的是，Sentry，我可以告诉你Sentry的历史，它是由一个人发起的，我忘了那个人的名字，但他当时在一家初创公司工作。他想要捕捉崩溃，然后还要捕捉面包屑，查看性能监控以及所有这些事情。其中一些事情，我的意思是你可以拼凑起来。所以你可以使用 OpenTelemetry 进行性能监控。有一些像 Rollbar 这样用于在崩溃报告器上捕获崩溃的东西。但并没有真正一个解决方案能面面俱到，并且拥有人们不得不把崩溃放到 Datadog 中并使用 Datadog 的模式查找功能的真正美观的界面，因为你可以想象你可能会得到 10,000 个崩溃，而这基本上都是同一个问题，只是带有，你知道的，“我期望 32，但我得到了 16”。我期望 30 或我期望，
I expected 32, but I got 17. I expect 32, but I got 18. It's like, how do you sort of turn that into a pattern that says, you know, this error happened, you know, 17 times, right? And so they did really nice sort of pattern, I guess, discovery and all of that. Actually, they, there's a whole bunch of cool papers on NLP stuff on how to do that, which they wrote. But so they did an amazing job of that. And then I think, I don't know if the company went under or if this person just left his startup, but he was able to take the IP with him and he just ended up creating that as a service. And to this day, Sentry, even the the server the sentry server is open source which
我期望 32，但我得到了 17。我期望 32，但我得到了 18。就像，你如何将它变成一种模式，说明“你知道，这个错误发生了 17 次”，对吧？所以他们做出了非常漂亮的模式发现以及所有这些。实际上，他们写了一整堆关于如何做到这一点的 NLP 酷论文。所以他们在这方面做得非常出色，然后我想，我不知道这家公司是倒闭了还是这个人只是离开了他的创业公司，但他能够把知识产权随身带走，他最后只是把那个做成了一项服务。直到今天，Sentry，甚至是 Sentry 服务器本身都是开源的，
is kind of mind-blowing yeah you can run a sentry server yourself with like one docker command but where they you know could like continue to make money is you know they have a version of sentry that's enterprise that has all the auditing so if if someone's like looking through all the errors you on the back end have a record like you know like looking through all the errors, you on the back end have a record like, you know, Adam looked through all these errors today, you know, Jason went to this project yesterday. And so, you know, companies, you know, that have a lot of liability, you know, that's really important to them. And so even though like literally everything in Sentry is open sourced, you know, they still have a viable business model wow i didn't realize the server was open source
这有点令人震撼。是的，你可以只用一个 Docker 命令自己运行一个 Sentry 服务器，但他们能够继续赚钱的地方在于，他们拥有一个企业版的 Sentry，其中包含所有的审计功能，因此如果有人正在查看所有的错误，你在后端会有一条记录，比如“亚当今天查看了所有这些错误”，“杰森昨天访问了这个项目”。因此，对于承担大量责任的公司来说，这非常重要，所以即使 Sentry 中的字面上的每一样东西都是开源的，他们仍然拥有一个可行的商业模式。哇，我没有意识到服务器是开源的。
that's interesting yeah there's a project in their organization their github organization called get century and it's their entire server wow yeah so after like after the whole red hat thing like after the many companies that tried to copy red hat with offering support like one of the other models that really took off is just software as a service so that you see this a lot wherein we make a product and it's open source if you run it yourself right but if you want it hosted somewhere and running on a server you know and you don't want to have to worry about setting it up, then we'll do that. So, you know, this is, I think like HashiCorp works like this, I believe, and a lot of database vendors work like this.
这很有趣。是的，在他们的组织中，在他们的 GitHub 组织中有一个名为 get-sentry 的项目，这就是他们的整个服务器。哇，是的，所以在经历整件事——在许多试图通过提供支持来复制红帽的公司之后，真正起飞的另一个模式就是软件即服务（SaaS），所以你会经常看到这一点，即我们制作了一个产品，如果你自己运行它，它是开源的，但如果你希望它托管在某处并在服务器上运行，而且你不想担心设置它，那么我们会为你做这件事。所以，这，我认为像 HashiCorp 就是这样运作的，我相信，许多数据库供应商也是这样运作的。
So you can use, what's an example? Yeah, what's the Mongo one called? It's like Mongo World or something. I want to look. Yeah, like Mongo. There's a self-hosted mongo db mongo db will have their own cloud i believe that confluent the kafka company has their own like host kafka in the cloud thing that you can use ah it's mongo db atlas that's what it's called
所以你可以使用，有什么例子吗？是的，那个叫 Mongo 的叫什么？它叫 Mongo World 还是别的什么？我想查一下。是的，就像 Mongo。有一个自托管的 MongoDB，MongoDB 将拥有他们自己的云，我相信 Confluent，那家 Kafka 公司，有他们自己的像在云中托管 Kafka 的东西，你可以使用它。啊，是 MongoDB Atlas，这就是它的名字。
and so that you know they hold all the data they take care of all of it for you you're a sandbox so you obviously can't see other people's data but they take care of all of it for you you're a sandbox so you obviously can't see other people's data but they take care of the whole platform yeah and then the interesting thing with databases in particular like would seem to be a very good fit for this model because you want people to take very good care of your data but there there is a hiccup right which is basically aws right if you have an open source database mongodb for instance and amazon can make a hosted version of it they may actually be better at building a hosted version of it than you are or at very least yeah they already have most of your customers already have an account there where they don't have an account with your service.
所以他们掌握了所有数据，他们为你处理好一切，你是一个沙盒，所以你显然看不到别人的数据，但他们为你处理好一切，你是一个沙盒，所以你显然看不到别人的数据，但他们处理整个平台。是的，接着关于数据库的有趣之处在于，特别是对于这种模型来说，似乎非常契合，因为你希望人们把你的数据照顾得非常好，但这里有一个小波折，对吧？基本上就是 AWS。如果你有一个开源数据库，例如 MongoDB，而亚马逊可以制作一个托管版本，他们实际上可能比你更擅长构建托管版本，或者至少，是的，他们已经拥有你的大多数客户，那些客户已经有那里的账户，而他们没有你服务的账户。
So this kind of concern about Amazon led to open source database companies to kind of shift licensing. So I think MariaDB was the first company to do a, I believe they call a source available license. So MariaDB is like a replacement for MySQL and it it's a commercial company, and you can access the source for it. They have a license that looks much like the Mozilla public license, except it says, you can't compete with us. You can't make any money doing something using this source that we do with it. So that's basically like, cloud providers you can't this isn't right and i think this has been a controversial thing in some areas you know because people are like is that really open source the source is available but you can't do whatever you want with it it is limited in certain cases yeah i mean it's a good question what was the amazon one called it was it called beanstalk or was that something else? I think. I'm going to look it up right now. Yeah, I don't know.
因此，这种对亚马逊的担忧导致开源数据库公司改变了许可协议。所以我认为 MariaDB 是第一家这样做的公司，我相信他们称之为源码可用许可证。因此，MariaDB 就像是 MySQL 的替代品，它是一家商业公司，你可以访问它的源码。他们有一个看起来非常像 Mozilla 公共许可证的许可证，除了它说：你不能与我们竞争。你不能利用我们用这个源码做的事情来赚钱。所以这基本上就像，云提供商不能——这不对，我认为这在某些领域是一个有争议的事情，你知道，因为人们会说：那真的是开源吗？源码是可用的，但你不能随心所欲地使用它，它在某些情况下是受限的。是的，我的意思是这是一个好问题，亚马逊那个叫什么名字？是叫 Beanstalk 还是别的什么？我想。我这就去查查。是的，我不知道。
Oh, I think. Okay. They used to have a name. I think they changed the name because they were getting in. Part of the problem was AWS basically made it seem, I think it was called Beanstalk, but they made it seem like this is AWS's take on MongoDB. When in fact, it literally was MongoDB. And so now they call it MongoDB on AWS. So they've sort of taken the blinds down on that. But yeah, that caused a huge stir, completely disrupted MongoDB's business model. The more extreme version of this is Docker,
哦，我想。好吧。他们以前有个名字。我想他们改了名字，因为他们卷入了。部分问题在于亚马逊基本上让它看起来——我想它叫 Beanstalk，但他们让它看起来这是 AWS 对 MongoDB 的演绎。而事实上，它字面意思就是 MongoDB。所以现在他们称之为 AWS 上的 MongoDB。所以他们基本上把盲板撤掉了。但是，是的，这引起了巨大的轰动，彻底颠覆了 MongoDB 的商业模式。更极端的版本是 Docker，
Swarm, and Kubernetes, where Kubernetesubernetes basically took the you know docker d and the daemon and all the the core from docker and built their own version of docker swarm that's just much better than docker swarm and uh just completely undercut docker's entire business model that's true although like the thing with kubernetes is that it is also open source so that's a good point so yeah i guess i guess it's it is also open source oh i see but it's i think it's really just that google can just afford to hemorrhage money on it and yeah exactly yeah the interesting one to me and i don't know all the history on it though is elastic search so ria db like they thought of this ahead of time they said we're going to use this license it's not
Swarm 和 Kubernetes，其中 Kubernetes 基本上拿走了 Docker 的守护进程（dockerd）和所有来自 Docker 的核心，并构建了自己的 Docker Swarm 版本，这比 Docker Swarm 好得多，而且完全削弱了 Docker 的整个商业模式。这倒也是，尽管 Kubernetes 的问题在于它也是开源的，所以这是一个好观点。所以，是的，我想，我想它也是开源的。哦，我明白了，但我认为这真的只是因为谷歌有能力在其上面烧钱，而且，完全正确。对我来说有趣的一个是 Elasticsearch，而且我并不了解它的全部历史。对于 MariaDB 来说，他们提前想到了这一点，他们说：我们将使用这个许可证，它不是
quite open source right and it basically says like not for you amazon elastic search was open source you know search databasey thing um like they had an apache license i believe and they started their own hosted cloud for Elasticsearch. They're like, we're really good at managing this distributed database. So let us do it. But Amazon also was really good at running Elasticsearch. And so Elasticsearch changed their license, like I think like a year or two ago,
完全开源，对吧？它基本上写着：亚马逊不适用。Elasticsearch 曾是开源的，你知道，搜索数据库类的东西，嗯，我想他们有一个 Apache 许可证，并且他们为 Elasticsearch 启动了自己的托管云。他们说：我们非常擅长管理这个分布式数据库，所以让我们来做吧。但亚马逊也非常擅长运行 Elasticsearch。因此 Elasticsearch 改变了他们的许可证，我想大约是一两年以前，
after, you know, like years of people contributing to it, thinking it was like true open source they changed the license to be sort of a source available license to prevent amazon from using it but they really upset a lot of people who were like i contributed to this project i thought it was open source and you're changing the license on me and so it's a tricky area yeah yeah it's it's wild yeah i i think you really have to be providing additional value i think that the license model it's just very tricky to get right i mean i wonder if there's any data on financially how that ended up like it's counterfactual right we'll never know what would have happened if they hadn't changed the license but what we could do is we could see okay once they change the license
在经历了多年人们为之贡献代码、以为它是真正的开源之后，他们将许可证更改为某种源码可用许可证，以防止亚马逊使用它。但他们惹恼了很多人，这些人说：“我为这个项目作出了贡献，我以为它是开源的，而你们却在改我的许可证。”所以这是一个棘手的领域。是的，是的，太疯狂了。是的，我认为你真的必须提供额外的价值，我认为许可证模型要做到恰到好处真的很棘手。我的意思是，我想知道是否有关于财务上的数据，最终结果如何？这是一个反事实，对吧？我们永远不会知道如果他们没有更改许可证会发生什么，但我们能做的是我们可以看到，好吧，一旦他们更改了许可证，
then i guess amazon would have to stop just having their own fork of elastic search and then how many people went to the elastic search it'd be really interesting to see a post-mortem on what the effect was of that yeah one thing amazon has now is is they used to host neo4j and now they wrote their own called neptune they have their own graph database and that's the other concern is is you know like you could have a really well-crafted license but then like what is your actual ip you know and what And if Amazon makes their own object database, how can you sort of prove that they took your idea, right? Yeah.
然后我想亚马逊将不得不停止拥有他们自己的 Elasticsearch 分支，然后有多少人去了 Elasticsearch？看看关于这产生的影响的复盘，会非常有趣。是的，亚马逊现在有的一点是，他们过去托管 Neo4j，现在他们编写了自己的名为 Neptune 的图数据库，他们有自己的图数据库，这就是另一个顾虑，你知道，就像你可以有一个精心制作的许可证，但随后，什么是你真正的知识产权，你知道的？如果亚马逊制作了他们自己的对象数据库，你将如何证明他们窃取了你的想法，对吧？是的。
And I believe with Elasticsearch that they rebranded their Elasticsearch type product to have a different name, but under the hood, it's probably the same thing. Yeah. Yeah. So not to say it's all doom and gloom though i think databases are are the trickiest area but if you look at
我相信对于 Elasticsearch 来说，他们将他们的 Elasticsearch 类型产品重新命名为不同的名字，但在底层，它可能是一样的东西。是的。是的，不过并不是说一切都一片黯淡，我认为数据库是最棘手的领域，但如果你看看
like wordpress is probably like one of the big successes in my mind yeah like i think like all of the internet uh runs on wordpress if you look close enough. Yeah, that's right. And it's completely open source and all they do is offer hosting for WordPress and people, you know, are happy to use wordpress.com because, hey, they're good at hosting WordPress. Yeah. WordPress is a great example. I'll give a little shout out to my wife. My wife has a site called, what is it called? I'm totally failing here. It's called Lone Star Family Fun. And so my wife has a site called, what is it called? I'm totally failing here. It's called Lone Star Family Fun. And so my wife has a site where she posts like fun things to do around Texas for kids, right?
WordPress 在我看来可能是巨大的成功之一。是的，就像我认为整个互联网都在运行 WordPress，如果你仔细看的话。是的，没错。而且它是完全开源的，他们所做的只是提供 WordPress 的托管，人们，你知道的，很高兴使用 WordPress.com，因为，嘿，他们很擅长托管 WordPress。是的，WordPress 是一个很好的例子。我要向我的妻子致敬。我妻子有一个网站，叫什么来着？我在这里彻底卡壳了。它叫 Lone Star Family Fun。所以我的妻子有一个网站，叫什么来着？我在这里彻底卡壳了。它叫 Lone Star Family Fun。所以我的妻子有一个网站，她在上面发布一些德克萨斯州适合小孩子的有趣事情，对吧？
So for families. And so I was helping her set it up years ago. And I knew that WordPress is gonna be the thing because she didn't have to do anything that complicated and WordPress super popular. But when you search for WordPress, you originally get like bluehost.com and some other ones. And so this is similar to what we were saying with Amazon, where someone is hosting WordPress. And so you could say they're kind of undercutting WordPress.
为了家庭。所以几年前我一直在帮她搭建。我知道 WordPress 会是首选，因为她不需要做任何那么复杂的事情，而且 WordPress 超级受欢迎。但当你搜索 WordPress 时，你最初会看到 Bluehost.com 和其他一些网站。所以这类似于我们之前关于亚马逊的说法，有人在托管 WordPress。所以你可以说他们有点在削减 WordPress。
And we ran Bluehost for less than a month. And then we ended up switching to wordpress proper and it was ultimately because of bad service so so this is like this is where what is it called like customer service is key right so wordpress you know even though it's open either open core or entirely open source and anyone can run their own wordpress site relatively easily. They have just phenomenal customer service and they've built a moat through interacting with a lot of people who want to start websites. So for example, in my case, I was there helping my wife out, but we'd go to Bluehost and they're asking all these really technical questions and what's your DNS entry and your CNAME name record and and he was able to do all this but normal person would just would have a lot of trouble there right someone who's not really tech savvy you know wordpress has all of
我们使用 Bluehost 的时间还不到一个月。然后我们最终转到了真正的 WordPress，这归根结底是因为糟糕的服务。所以，这就是——什么是客户服务至关重要的地方，对吧？所以 WordPress，即使它是开源的、开放核心的或者是完全开源的，任何人都可以相对轻松地运行他们自己的 WordPress 网站。他们拥有非凡的客户服务，并且通过与许多想要建立网站的人互动建立了一条护城河。例如，在我的情况下，我在那里帮我妻子，但我们会去 Bluehost，他们会问所有这些非常技术性的问题，比如你的 DNS 记录是什么、你的 CNAME 记录是什么，他能够做到这一切，但普通人会遇到很多麻烦，对吧？对技术不太精通的人，你知道 WordPress 拥有所有
those battle scars from putting up so many sites right and so they the wordpress site creator like almost knows what you want and it's like an eight ball magic eight ball it narrows down what you want and then gives it to you so so all of that is to say that you could easily build uh you know an open core open source project that is and monetize that project through just you know relentless you know care and and love for your customers. Yeah, totally. I feel like it's interesting. If I were building an open source product project, like I like to make like command line tools and stuff, right? So I could start making that if I were following some of these things we discussed, right.
那些建立过如此多网站的战伤累累的经验，所以 WordPress 网站创建者几乎知道你想要什么，它就像一个魔幻8球一样，缩小了你想要的范围，然后把它交给你。所以，所有这些都是为了说明，你可以轻松构建一个开源核心/开源项目，并通过对客户不懈的关怀和爱来将该项目货币化。是的，完全如此。我觉得这很有趣。如果我要构建一个开源项目产品，就像我喜欢制作命令行工具之类的东西，对吧？所以如果我遵循我们讨论过的一些事情，我可以开始制作它，对吧。
If I might want to build up a community, so like get on Twitch or something and like show people how I build it, build up a following around that make it open source but then like it's hard past that getting supporters like how would you get people to pay for a developer command line tool well people don't really pay for developer command line tools right like that's not i mean maybe some but the next thing i would probably try is like oh are there like software as a service components that that i would add right like is there okay it's a command line tool but maybe
如果我可能想建立一个社区，比如上 Twitch 之类的平台，向人们展示我是如何构建它的，围绕它建立一个粉丝群体，把它开源，但在这之后很难获得支持者——你将如何让人们为一个开发人员命令行工具付费？好吧，人们实际上并不为开发人员命令行工具付费，对吧？那不是——我的意思是也许有些会，但我接下来可能会尝试的是：“哦，是否有我可以添加的软件即服务组件？”比如：“好吧，它是一个命令行工具，但也许有些东西我可以在云端做，从而减轻一些负担。”就像 Earthly 一样，它是一个构建工具，所以你可以在 Jenkins 中使用它，但我们的最终计划是在云端拥有我们自己的类似构建服务器的东西，并且由于我们构建事物的方式，我们将能够比 CircleCI 更快地构建人们的软件。想想看。好吧，我想构建一些人们可以使用的非常酷的开源东西。然后如果我想把它带到下一个阶段，企业愿意为什么付费？他们有什么问题？是的。
there's something i can do in the cloud that kind of alleviates some of the burden like with earthly it's a build tool and so you can use it in jenkins but our ultimate plan is to have our own like kind of build servers in the sky and because of the way we've structured things, we will be able to build people's software much faster than, you know, CircleCI think about that. Like, okay, I want to build something really cool that's open source for people to use. And then if I want to take it to the next stage, like what do businesses, you know, what are they willing to pay for? What are the problems they have? Yep. Yeah, that makes sense. I think too, with open source, I got a lot of pushback when I added instrumentation to Eternal Terminal. You know, people were very sensitive to that and to this day you know every now and then we'll get an issue you know now it's like every time someone this is kind of like a bit of a tangent but anytime i see an issue that's related to documentation or
是的，这说得通。我也认为，对于开源，当我向 Eternal Terminal 添加插桩（instrumentation）时，我遭到了很多反对。你知道，人们对此非常敏感，直到今天，你知道，时不时地我们会收到一个问题，你知道，现在就像每当有人——这有点像题外话，但每当看到与文档或类似东西相关的问题时，我总是告诉那个人：“提交一个 PR，即使它是冗余的文档，这也意味着那个人没有在我们放置它的地方找到那个项目，对吧？”所以提交一个 PR，无论你写什么，我们都会把它放到网站上。所以现在大多数人对此都相当随和，你可以关闭它。但是添加插桩遭到了很多反对。而且没有办法隐藏它。这是一个开源项目。所以每个人都可以去看代码，然后看到：“哦，你知道，当发生崩溃时，它会去把崩溃发送到某个地方的网络端点。”所以我为此遭到了很多反对。但我真的很高兴我这么做了。因为即使你知道，当发生崩溃时，它会去把崩溃发送到某个地方的网络端点，所以所以我为此遭到了很多反对，但我真的很高兴我这么做了，因为尽管我
something like that i always tell the person like file a pr and even if it's redundant documentation it means that person didn't find that item where, you know, we put it, right? So file a PR and whatever you write, we'll put it into the site. And so now most people are pretty copacetic with it, you can turn it off. But there's a lot of pushback with adding instrumentation. And there's no way to hide it. It's an open source project. So everyone can go to the code and see, oh, you know, when there's a crash, you know, it goes and sends a crash to some web endpoint somewhere. So I got a lot of pushback for that. But I'm really glad that I did. Because even you know when there's a crash you know it goes and sends a crash to some web endpoint somewhere so so i got a lot of pushback for that but i'm really glad that i did because even though i'm
没有从 Eternal Terminal 赚到任何钱，但开发人员体验对我的重要性依然存在，所以我仍然努力用我能花在上面的微薄时间让它变得更好；所以，你知道，在那种情况下，有一些清晰的事情我们可以做来让它变得更好。我可以列出前 10 件我可以用来改进它的事情清单。所以你需要这样做，收集这些数据，并专注于给人们他们想要的以及对他们而言重要的价值。你将听到很多我们已经讨论过的事情。有些事情对创作者来说实际上并不那么重要，比如审计。很少有制作开源工具的人会关心有人访问该工具的这个部分多少次。但公司关心，对吧？那可能意味着，你知道，构建对你来说不是那么有趣，但对那家公司非常重要的事情，并允许，你知道，你获得资助来构建所有其他东西。这类似于回到你的例子，你知道，米开朗基罗，你知道，当时的人们做了很多宗教和文化偶像以及这些东西，因为那是带来账单的原因，对吧？而且其中许多人非常虔诚，所以他们不是愤世嫉俗者或别的什么，但你知道，那是带来账单的原因，然后他们就可以，你知道，做他们的艺术品和手艺，并同时做这两件事。是的，我刚才在想，如果你想制作——是的，就像想象一下，你为 Eternal Terminal 收到了很多请求，他们希望某种方式拥有
not making any money from eternal terminal it still matters to me the developer experience and so i still strive to make that better with you know a little time i have that i can spend on it and so you know in the case of, there are clear things that we can do to make it better. And I could come up with like a top 10 list of things that I would do to improve it. And so you need to do that, collect that data and focus on giving people what they want and what value matters to them. And you'll hear a lot of things we talked about already. There are things that don't really matter to the creator very often, like auditing. Very few people who make an open source tool care how many times someone goes to this part of the tool. But companies care, right? that might mean, you know, building things that aren't that interesting to you, but are really
一个中央服务器，这样他们既可以——这样他们就可以通过主动连接而不是被动连接来突破防火墙，那么那可能是一个商业的（你知道的）附加组件，哦，你将以某种方式将连接反射到某个中央服务器上。哦，是的，是的，就像——那叫什么来着，当他们做 WebRTC 时，如果你不能做一个穿透，你可以使用一个 TURN 服务器来反射信息。是的，我认为你知道，对于使用终端的公司来说，我认为他们中的很多人你知道都想要审计，想要能够说：“好吧，谁登录了这个机器，登录了多久”，这绝对是一个商业需求。这里另一个这样做正确的例子是，我们在节目中采访过他们，
important for that company and allow, you know, you to be funded to build everything else. And this is similar to going back to your example, you know, Michelangelo, you know, people at the time did a lot of like religious and cultural icons and these things, because that's what brought in the bills, right? And a lot of these people were really religious so so they're not cynics or anything but you know that's what brought in the bills and then they could you know do like their artwork and their craft and and do both of those at the same time yeah i was just thinking like if you wanted to make yeah like what imagine you got a lot of requests for eternal terminal that they wanted like some way to have
就是 Vercel。Vercel 制作了 Next.js，他们还制作了一个名为 Vercel 的托管系统。所以你可以做类似 NextUp 之类的东西。默认情况下它会选择 Vercel，尽管它是开源的，所以你可以选择其他东西，它会把你的网站获取并发布到 Vercel。所以 AWS，亚马逊在这期播客中看起来像个混蛋，但事实就是如此。所以亚马逊制作了自己的 Vercel 版本，叫做 Amplify。而用户体验简直糟糕透顶。它根本无法运行。我遇到了太多的错误。我会浏览 GitHub 问题，找到有相同错误的问题，有很多点赞却没有进展。所以他们只是不知道，这是一个大卫与歌利亚的例子，你知道，尽管 Vercel 只有，我想说可能 200 名工程师吧，也许这有点慷慨，但他们能够提供真正美好的体验。所以，你知道，作为一个最终用户，我尝试了 Amplify，几乎立刻就回到了 Vercel，因为 Vercel 从未出过故障，即使在我更新项目时也是如此。是的，这是一个超级有趣的例子。而且我认为如果你正在构建一个开源项目，因为你想让它存在于这个世界上，然后，好吧，如果我获得资金，我可以投入更多资源，我认为你的方法与那种说“哦，是的，这是要在我们的云中运行的另一件事”的组织是不同的。
a central server so that they could both you know so they could punch out through firewalls by you know reaching out instead of in then that might be like a commercial you know add-on like oh you'll somehow reflect the connections off some central server oh yeah yeah like like what is that called you know when they do the web rtc and if you can't do a punch through a turn like a turn server that like reflects the information yeah i think you know for companies using a terminal i think a lot of them you know want auditing i want the ability to say okay who logged into this machine and for how long and that's definitely a business need um another example here of someone doing this right is, and we had them on the show,
是的，就像，我认为你对这个过程投入得更多。是的，有一个很酷的工具叫 buf，只有一个 f，buf。它就像是一个 gRPC 和 Protobuf 校验器（linter），所以他们拥有——它是开源的命令行工具，但他们有一些额外的功能，比如你可以记录文档，或者我忘了他们的——我忘了他们的功能补充是什么，但它们都托管在他们的网站上，对吧？所以有点像——哦，就像一个用于你的 Protobuf 文件的模式注册表（schema registry），你可以托管在他们那里。但就像我与那里的某些开发人员交谈过一样，他们真的很关心 Protobufs，以及人们一直在错误地使用它们，你知道，这里是人们在使用 gRPC 时遇到的问题。我认为资助一个开源项目的真正秘密是，它是你真正（你知道的）充满激情的东西，并且你知道你想要与人们谈论它，你想要让它变得更好。是的，这说得通。我想，那么——也许我们将通过讨论来结束它，我们将轮流讨论如何——你可以让你的项目获得资助，或者这需要什么。我认为我们在这里谈得很具体，但从我的角度来看，许多构建事物的人都是热爱系统和事物的人，因此主动去招揽客户并不是直觉反应。去成为产品代言人并不是直觉反应，
is Vercel. So Vercel makes Next.js and they also make a hosting system called Vercel. And so you can do like NextUp or something like that. And it will by default pick Vercel, although it's open source, so you could pick other things and it would take your site and publish it to Vercel. So AWS, and so Amazon's going to come off looking like a jerk in this podcast, but it is what it is. So Amazon made their own version of Vercel called Amplify. And the user experience is just terrible. It doesn't work. I ran into so many errors. I would go through GitHub issues and find issues with the same error and so many thumbs ups and no progress. And so they just didn't know, there's a David and Goliath example, you know, even though Vercel is, I want to say maybe 200 engineers, maybe that's being generous, they're able to provide just a really nice experience. And so, you know, as an end user, I tried Amplify and went back to Vercel like almost right away because Vercel's never not worked even as I've updated the project. Yeah, that's a super interesting example. And I think if you're building an open source project, because like you want it to exist in the world, and then like, okay, I can put more resources into it. If I get funded, I think you approach it differently than an organization that's like, Oh, yeah, another thing to run in our cloud.
然后出去征求意见并构建其他人想要的产品，对吧？所以大多数产品，比如红帽，它最初是一个爱好项目，这个人正在为自己构建一些东西。所以在某种程度上，你必须审视镜子并构建
Yeah, like, I think you're much more invested in the process yeah there's a cool tool called buff it's like with one f buf uh it's like a grpc and protobuf linter and so they have it's open source their command line tool but then they have some additional features where like you can document things or i forget what their i forget what their feature ads are but they're all like kind of hosted on their website right so there's kind of like a oh like a schema registry for your protobuf files that you can host with them but like i talked to some of the developers there and they just care like really a lot about protobufs and the people have been using them wrong and you know here's problems that people
适合其他所有人的产品。这是一个艰难的转变，你随处可见。我认识音乐家，我有朋友是音乐家，但他们只是为自己创作音乐，所以你知道，这有点难以解释。对于音乐来说，这在软件中要清晰得多，但最终，你知道，我朋友的音乐在某些领域变得超级技术化，大多数人无法真正欣赏，这有点像攀登他们在掌握乐器时所面临的挑战，没有人能真正产生共鸣，对吧？这就像是一样的道理，你知道，你必须非常擅长自己开始或者和一个小团队开始，并构建一个需要很长时间的东西，独自在地下室里花费许多个小时。
hit with grpc i think that really the real secret to to funding an open source project is like that it's something that you're really you know impassioned about and you know you want to talk to people about it and you want to make it better yeah that makes sense and i guess so so maybe we'll end it by just talking about we'll take turns talking about how like uh how you can get your project funded or what it takes and i think we talked very mechanically here but from my perspective a lot of people who build things are people who love systems and love things and so it's not intuitive to then sort of go out and solicit. It's not intuitive to sort of be like a product advocate
但同时也具备那些技能走出去，询问受众，征求反馈并构建一个生态系统。所以要拥有一个非常成功的财务开源项目，你必须做这两件事，你知道，要么作为合作伙伴关系，要么靠你自己。是的，我完全同意。是的，就像我心目中的关键点一样，如果你有一个开源项目，就像“我构建了一些东西，我认为它挺酷的。”然后我把它扔出去供自己使用。那很棒。如果你真的想获得大量的吸引力，可能重要的是你正在解决其他人遇到的问题，而且通常情况下，你知道，事实就是如此，你知道，“我有一个问题，我为此构建了一个工具，其他人也有这个问题”，但你唯一能发现这一点的方法可能是通过与人交谈，你知道，就像——问问你知道可能会使用这个项目其他人，这是否有帮助。
and go out and solicit advice and build the product that other people want, right? And so most products like a Red Hat, for example, it started as like a hobby project where this person was building something for themselves. And so then at some point, you have to sort of look behind the mirror and build
就像，你知道，Earthly，我提到了 CI 构建失败并试图摆弄它的那个问题，针对这个问题有很多解决方案，但我认为重要的是，通常当我与人们交谈并有这种抱怨时，他们会立刻理解，“哦，是的，这很痛。”所以我想你需要这样的东西，你需要有一个清晰的问题陈述，你会说“很多人都有这个问题，即使我不打算用这个做成一笔生意，你知道，我只知道如果我构建这个开源项目，它将满足很多人的利益。”完全说得通，我认为这是一个完美的结束方式。亚当，非常感谢你来到节目中，担任客座主持人。我们有过很多嘉宾。这是我们第一次有客座主持人。我认为有你加入真是太棒了。一期非常精彩的节目。再次感谢你抽出时间来到节目中。是的。谢谢邀请我。我很抱歉。我有点咳嗽，而且我吃了很多咳嗽药。所以希望我说的一切都是连贯的。听起来完全没问题。很多人不知道，你知道，
the product for everybody else that's a hard transition and you see it everywhere i know musicians i have friends who are musicians but they're only making the music for themselves and and so that you know just it's kind of like a hard thing to explain for music it's much more clear in software but it ends up being you know my friend's music ends up being like super technical in certain areas that most people can't really appreciate and it's sort of like climbing on top of challenges that they faced in their mastery of their instrument that like no one else can really relate to right and it's the same kind of thing where you know you're going to have to really be good at starting on your own or with a small group and building something that's going to take a long time, many hours by yourself in your basement.
对于双人节目——一个不是——甚至对于采访节目，你知道，我们做了很多准备工作。在任何播客的幕后都有很多工作要做，我们的也是，
But then also have those skills to go out, ask the audience, solicit feedback and build an ecosystem. So to have a really successful financial open source project, you have to do both of those things, you know, either as a partnership or by yourself. Yeah, I totally agree. And yeah, like the key in my thinking, like, if you're having an open source project, like just, you know, I built something, I think it's kind of cool. And I throw it up for myself. That's great. if you really want to build a lot of traction probably it's just important that you are solving a problem that other people have and and oftentimes you know that's just the case like you know i have a problem and i build a tool for it and other people have it but the only real way you can find that out is probably by talking to people you know like just like ask you know other people who you think might use this project if it would be helpful
我们的也是。所以这是一项巨大的努力。再次感谢亚当的到来，这是一期精彩的节目。对于外面的朋友们，我们还有一些排好的采访，但我们可能会在接下来的几个月里
like you know earthly you know i kind of mentioned that problem of like having the build fail in ci and trying to have to poke with it you know there's many solutions to that problem but i think what's important is that like usually when i talk to people and i have that complaint like they immediately understand like oh yeah that's a pain and so i think you want something like that you want to have a problem like a clear problem statement you're like a lot of people have this problem and even if i'm not going to make a business out of this you know i just know if i build this open source project that it will serve a lot of people's interest totally makes sense i think it's a phenomenal way to end it. So Adam, thanks so much for coming
做一些双人节目。非常感谢你们的收听，感谢你们对节目的支持。如果你想看亚当的节目，这个节目叫做 Co-Recursive Podcast。它太棒了。我最近采访了——我们谈到了我们在开始录音之前你提到的那个——是的，那是直播吗？好吧，它不是，它将是
on the show, being a guest host. We've had a lot of guests. This is our first time with a guest host. I think it was awesome to have you on board. A really great episode. And thank you again for putting in the time and coming on the show. Yeah. Thanks for having me. I apologize. I got a bit of a cough and I took a lot of cough medicine. So hopefully everything I've said is coherent. It sounds totally fine. A lot of folks don't know that, you know,
5 月 1 日或 2 日。啊，太酷了。所以你会听到亚当和一位在火星车上工作的绅士之间的采访，这真是太酷了。再次感谢亚当，感谢收听的朋友们，我们几周后见。音乐由 Eric Barnella 提供。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可证下分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输
for the, for a duo episode, you know, an episode that isn't, and even for the interview episodes, you know, we do a lot of prep works. There's a lot that goes behind the scenes on really any podcast and ours,
作品，进行混音、改编作品，但你必须署名我和帕特里克，并以相同方式共享。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任意句子发表评论。
ours as well. So it's a huge effort. Thanks again, Adam, for coming on and a phenomenal episode. For folks out there, we have a couple more interviews lined up, but we will probably do a couple of duo episodes as well
我们也是。所以这花费了巨大的精力。再次感谢亚当的到来，这是一期精彩绝伦的节目。各位听众，我们接下来还有几次采访，不过在接下来的几个月里，我们可能也会做几期双人节目
over the next couple of months. And thanks so much for listening, for supporting the show. And if you want to catch Adam's show, this show is called the Co-Recursive Podcast. It's phenomenal. I recently interviewed interviewed we talked about the one we that you mentioned before we uh started recording yeah is that live okay it's not it'll be
非常感谢大家的收听和对节目的支持。如果你想收听亚当的节目，这个节目叫做《Co-Recursive Podcast》。它太棒了。我最近采访了……我们讨论了之前提到的那个，在我们开始录音之前……是的，那个上线了吗？好吧，还没有，它将会在
it'll be may may 1st or 2nd ah cool so you'll hear an interview between adam and a gentleman who worked on the mars rover which is uh super super cool so thanks again adam thanks folks out there for listening and we will catch you on a couple of weeks. Music by Eric Barnella. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share Alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit
5月1日或2日发布。啊，太酷了。所以你会听到亚当与一位参与火星车研发的先生的访谈，这真的是超级超级酷。再次感谢亚当，感谢各位听众的收听，我们几周后见。片头曲由Eric Barnella制作。《Programming Throwdown》根据知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输
the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in time. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
该作品，进行混音、改编，但你必须署名我和帕特里克，并以相同方式共享。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。